Now we go from one grifter to another. Okay,
because I I only just saw this. I don't know. I guess got released
earlier today. My YouTube algorithm needs to get fixed. I was
not immediately alerted to the existence of TwitchCon liability
nightmare. Fast facts. Okay, fast facts. We're going to hear
about how bad it's going to get for TwitchCon specifically. All
right, that's facts. Now, here's the real question. Are we going
to get fast facts or are we going to have like another 5minute
diet tribe about how he's being gangstaled before we get no facts
and then another 5minute diet tribe that's barely adjacent to
the title? Which one is it this time? Which one? I feel like
he's going to stick to the facts this time. Maybe he'll even
meme on meme on himself a little bit. Okay, let's check it out.
Legal mindset, >> TwitchCon did not go well and we're going to
talk about it today on the episode of Legal Mindset. We teach
you to be your own judge. Course I'm Andrew Esquire, American
attorney. I'm back after a short break. It's good to be back
with you guys and it's good to have some time for myself. Dude,
I can't I can't now unsee unfortunately the eye thing. Okay,
I don't know if you guys I don't know if you guys saw the queen
thumbnail. Okay,
but like the now I can't unsee the eye thing because of the Queenman
thumbnail. It is It is awoken me. A Yeah, awoken me to the legal
mindset.
Eyes shift. I don't even know how to describe it.
Hold on. Let me let me go find this queen and thumbnail real
quick. Let me let me take a look.
Hold on. I'll pull it up for you guys. Give me a second.
I I see this now when I look at Andrew. This is what I'm seeing.
Okay. This is This is what I'm seeing. I just I can't It's like
so pronounced now that I see it. It's so pronounced as up.
My god. All right.
Okay. Hold on. Hold on.
Oh, I need to join my Discord. One second. One second. >> He's
got the
>> He's got those shooter eyes. >> He does. >> Like
the dude who assassinated Kirk. >> The sharpshooter eyes.
>> he hit a guy with a boltaction rifle from 500 yards.
Let's go. >> Yeah, but he's like not skilled. So, every
time he tries to aim at the point, he misses it clearly. >> I'll
give you a second if you want to join the Discord and join the
>> Boom. Boom. Boom. Okay.
All right. Let's uh let's keep going. We're watching Fast Facts.
Now, the big thing with Legal Mindset is he's always going to
take whatever side is winning in some online drama. He will take
the winning side side and explain how the law can be used to
sue somebody or jail somebody and it will not correspond with
reality at all. It'll be completely insane. All right. He's probably
going to say something here about how Twitch is liable because
they wouldn't let Emir have her favorite her absolute favorite
security guard. Almost certainly. How could we hear her before
she joined? Cuz she's in the same room. We're on the same audio
chain. >> Yeah. I only joined so he can share a >> Yeah.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. You'll also because we're on the same
audio chain, you'll see my face move when she talks, but don't
worry about it. Don't worry about it. Just pretend you don't
see it.
Uh, hey JC, I have a question. There's speculation that Tucker
is going to interview Fentes. Who do you think will win that
confrontation? I don't know if it'll be a confrontation, to tell
you the truth, Victor Sharp. >> Oh my god. I hope it is.
>> I I don't think I think Tucker knows he's owned. I don't
think Tucker will try to fight him. >> Uh
I loved the overlap of fighting at like Teeone saying, "I didn't
know about my father until Hassan said something." And Tucker
Carlson like, "I didn't know about my dad until Nick Fuentes
said
is very Yeah, I remember that. It was a crazy mirroring. All
right. And we had a lot of indication that both were lying. Like
both had made statements about that exact thing before they found
out about it so-called, right? >> But they just wanted
to focus on how bad that person was, >> how bad uh Hassan
was or how bad Nick Fuentes was.
>> You'd assume it would be contentious because um
like Dave Smith, he's a Candace Owens friend or whatever. So,
we thought that that would be more contentious and Dave Smith
just rolled over and took it in the ass. >> I think Yeah,
I think >> Tucker is going to lube up and just take >> I
I think that's if I had to guess. Yes,
I think so. Not Not if Nick presses, but Nick never presses.
If you're going to leave something like where Nick won on the
internet and you're going to leave it alone, he's not going to
press it. He'll let you He'll go, "Okay."
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> He'll laugh at you and be like, "Yeah,
that's what some people >> Yeah. Exactly. >> He'll
make you look silly." Yeah. But he won't he won't like press
Tucker on it. I think they'll have a totally like it'll be like
the Dave Smith combo. I think I think that's how it'll go. Yeah.
>> All right, let's uh uh so let's get right into it. We've
got of course a PP for you today. A nice PowerPoint uh on the
death of Twitch. It's actually several issues that are really
compounding for Twitch. Some of which we've been talking about
on this channel for a very long time. So, uh, of course, uh,
the main one, the one that everyone's talking about in the kind
of main death nail I'm seeing here for Twitch is the Emiru assault.
Uh, and that is due to the failure or lack of security at TwitchCon.
She was denied her own bodyguard. Uh, there was an
Oh god, there's no way. Denied her own bodyguard. There's no
way that he confuses this, right? She wasn't denied her own bodyguard.
Her own bodyguard stopped the thing from happening. a bodyguard
she had used in the past had physically restrained somebody and
because of that he couldn't come back to TwitchCon. That is an
entirely different >> which we got clarification on a bodyguard
two TwitchCons ago. >> So it's not like she had this one
last TwitchCon and everything was fine and now this TwitchCon
he's clearly like the missing piece of the puzzle. Yeah. >> Yes.
Yep.
>> Twitch death nails. Emiru assaulted due to failure/
lack of security at TwitchCon. Chippy doi meet and greet mistakes.
I don't even know what this is. This is definitely going to be
some Vtuber thing he's upset about. Andrew is like, "There was
supposed to be a virtual meet and greet. I set everything up.
I paid for the express ticket and I couldn't meet Chibi." That's
definitely what he's going to be talking about. >> Is that
the VTuber that was next to Emu? >> I have no idea. I don't
know who Chibiidoki is. Okay. I I don't think so. I think I heard
the name of the person who was next to Amiru and it wasn't. >> They're
a VTuber. So, you kind of don't want to know who they are. >> I
actually don't know that they're a VTuber. I made that assumption
based on the name >> and based on legal mindset's interest.
>> If I don't know about it and legal mindset knows about
it, it's I I can make some some assumptions here. Okay. >> Individual
came up and attempted to hug, grab, grope her uh without any
permission warning whatsoever.
And that is a major major issue particularly since we know that
Twitch has had security issues in the past. Then we had a bunch
of bungled mistakes with ChibiDoki's meet and greet uh in which
she was at first denied entry. There's some reports that she
was forced to unmask herself in front of certain people in order
to identify herself and then cutting that meet and greet short.
So, a lot of problems there. Then you've got Hassan, the golden
boy of Twitch under pressure, uh which once again, while not
happening at TwitchCon, happening around the same time as TwitchCon,
indeed is not good for Twitch. That's their golden boy. That's
Dan Clancy's favorite and that's an obvious problem for them.
And then the >> is the okay >> last and one of the
most >> guys Hassan is in drama. This is the end of Twitch.
They certainly don't benefit from this Hassan drama at all. They
certainly don't benefit from the Asenol versus Assan stuff going
on right now. No benefit whatsoever. >> Important is the
lack of moderation of Twitch content which perhaps is the most
damaging and puts them in a category along with Roblox in terms
of potential regulatory action. So, let's start with Emiru's
claim. So, obviously, if you saw in the video, and most people
have seen the video, you can watch that in my live version, which
we go over everything and all the video, all the facts. Uh, but
if you saw that, you saw that, hey, she was she had concerns.
She has a history of stalkers that have come after her. There's
a massive history of security issues at TwitchCon, uh, and with
Twitch events in general. Uh, and therefore, there are several
causes of action that she could pursue. First, there's the general
negligence theory. So that's essentially broad negligence for
failure to detain the individual. They just let him walk out.
They failed to coordinate with law enfor
>> So I I would just wonder if Emir has private security
who had physically touched the guy and saw the incident. Would
it not be on Emiru's private security before TwitchCon security?
Like if she literally has somebody who's meant to restrain people
doing this, would it not be on her to detain there >> forcemen?
Uh really they bungled that overall. But beyond that, there's
a more specific negligent security claim. So >> uh it also
says or uh for failure to detain or coordinate with law enforcement.
They explicitly said they were coordinating with law enforcement.
They explicitly said we will do everything we can to coordinate
with law enforcement and that they did so. >> Essentially
the organizer failed to provide adequate measures to prevent
the incident. So sufficiently trained personnel, barriers, etc.
Things they could have done to protect Emu and the streamer.
Of course, they did not do that. And given the fact that in 2019,
2022, 2024, and earlier this year in Roderdam in 2025, there
were significant security issues, they should have known, this
was not a first off. This is not a first time event. This is
not something they shouldn't know about. Uh Dan Clancy tried
to play this off as, oh, this is just something that happens
and it's normal and it's a sign of the times and you know, streamer.
There's no [__] way. Hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Did he say it's
like normal for this to h I think he said like listen it's a
massive thing. Um there are there will be security things that
happen or something. But he did say it was normal or okay. I
didn't get that and I was >> a sign of the times. >> A
sign of the times.
>> This this assault is just a sign of the times. There's
nothing we could do, boys. It's nothing. We're out. I don't feel
like he said that >> off as oh this is just something that
happens and it's normal and it's a sign of the times and you
know streamers can control their their community that doesn't
work as an organizer when you put together an event you have
a responsibility for that event to be safe particularly if there
are known risks and streamers are at risk when they're out there
not just from parasocial fans but people that want to hurt them
or harm them that's obviously something that is out there uh
and then you of course have breach of contract so there may have
been safety provisions and I don't know this this is my speculation.
Uh there may have been some provisions in her contract. So if
I was her agent or if I were her himself, I would go to a lawyer
and say, "Hey, look, is there anything in my contract here that
was breached?" Cuz it very well may have been something breached
in that contract. The last he said something like this is where
the world is now. Okay, let's look at the Well, is was that to
Taylor Loren then? Is that where that comment would have been
made? Because we could go review those Taylor Loren clips again.
I forgot about the Taylor Loren thing I quote tweeted as well.
So, I'm going to pull that up right now cuz I thought that was
>> It just it just can't be true to say, "Oh, it's a sign
of the time or this is just what the world is right now." Every
instance that becomes
like a story or a scandal is a a story or a scandal because it's
like an outlier.
It's not normal. This shouldn't happen. >> Yeah. No, everybody's
outraged. Yeah. You can't say when everybody's outraged, you
cannot say it's a sign of the times or or something like that.
>> We'll uh we'll see. I just thought it was really funny
that um earlier today, Taylor Loren tweeted, "This is a big H3H3
Productions thing." Taylor Loren's interview with Dan Clansancy
was one of the most pathetic forms of journalism I've ever seen
and further solidifies that she's a total hack with conflicts
of interest. Any half-co competent journalist, especially any
half-conmpetent female journalist in the postmeto era, would
have observed what happened to Emiru being in very real danger
and of getting unalived on day one of TwitchCon and the catastrophic
security failures that led to the guy getting that close to her
and then freely being able to walk away. And couple this with
so many female streamers refusing to attend because of safety
concerns, then any half-conmpetent journalist would have hammered
Dan Clansancy on this absolute disaster that happened at his
event
that as the CEO of Twitch he is responsible for.
Instead, Taylor Ren gives the softball softest of softball interviews,
unironically praises the security of the event and allows that
she did not praise it. She literally said it was like she was
like literally annoyed. She was doing the Hassan Diva. Uh yeah,
well like you guys I had a hard time getting in here. She was
like complaining about how much she got harassed trying to get
into the event or something. >> Who is this? >> Taylor
Loren. Oh,
so she praises security at the event and allows Dan Clansancy
to engage in corporate speak as well as victim blaming Emiru
for what happened to her. And the reason Loren got the interview
in the first place is that she is too big too she is she too
is a big uncritical fan of Clancy's favorite streamer Hassan
which guaranteed a softball interview. Dan Clansancy needs to
be fired and this excuse for an interview right after a prominent
female streamer gets essayed at what was meant to be a safe and
secure event should attract way more criticism and exposure of
Lorenza's so-called journalism and conflicts of interest. And
Taylor Lorenza's response was, "My interview with Dan Clansancy
isn't even out yet. It's going up on Wednesday on my YouTube
podcast, but Ethan Klein's fandom is already claiming it's pathetic
and fake journalism. Guys, the interview has not been published
yet.
This is The interview is literally not out.
We pointed this out on stream that people were freaking out about
her interview and it's not even public. It's like literally one
question where she's asking about the assault. Yes. No, this
is real, Bacto. The the interview is not actually out yet. >> Yeah,
this happened yesterday, right? You went over Yeah. Yeah. Uh
maybe two days ago, maybe two days ago, >> two days ago
>> or or yesterday, one of the two. >> But somebody
put out that she did like the softball interview and you're like,
"Wait, was it out? I think I just saw a clip of it." That's There's
only a clip. >> Yeah, it's Yeah, it's just the clip two
days ago on >> and you talked about how she's like the
germaphobe or whatever, and that's why she wears the masks. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. And so I just I thought it was crazy that from a
two-minute clip, maybe even a two-minute and then a three-minute
clip, people are saying that she's pathetic and she's incapable
of journalism. >> Fell Pow Cherry, what would you have
done in Emy's shoes?
As in, oh, if a fat incel tried to forcibly kiss me, I might
be small. I might be short, but I'd still swing. >> You
clock that guy. >> I got You have an advantage being short.
Okay. The person might be fat. They might be tall.
Get down. Get them at like the shins. Get them at the the ankles.
Trip their
>> Hit them in the nuts. >> The battle of Hoth plan.
I like it. >> Or just drop. Stop, drop, and roll. I don't
know why, but fat people, if they bend down, they're not getting
back up. I can stop, drop, and roll and get right the back up
and run. >> That guy was tall, too. His center of gravity
was not low. He would have had a rough time. Oh, Bacto, you're
so funny. Yeah, that was not low hanging fruit at all. Congratulations,
placeto
>> Loser. Nothing.
Don't nothing. He said nothing. All right. Uh let's keep going
with the >> this one though. And I think this one is the
most poignant is the post incident handling leading to intentional
infliction of emotional distress. I think a lot of things such
as them
>> are we just going to skate past how much that that subreddit
post sounds like Dan on this stream like a year ago? Oh yeah.
No, it's totally like
Dan Clancy needs to get fired. >> Yeah, it's it's like
one to one propaganda. Absolutely. It is
>> Yeah. I don't know. I don't And it's like here's the
thing. I have no doubt by the way that Taylor Loren will do a
softball interview with Dan Clansancy. Like I'm not I'm not even
in doubt of that. But it looks so bad when you start actually
saying that that's what's happening before it's happened. Like
it's it's crazy.
It's it anyway. And we I I can't remember where I saw the comments.
Oh, it was under the O tweet. It was some Oct tweet. >> Do
you have the replies to the
>> Uh we could find them pretty easily. >> But what
were you saying about the comments on Ox? >> Well, I think
that was just what led me to go, dude, the interview's not out
yet
Like we we saw somebody freaking out like this on Twitter with
the same comments that it's a total softball interview, that
it's complete that she would do that in in in the Age of Me Too.
It was like the exact It's like they had a script. It's like
they're running the same script. >> It's like they've got
that um that rapid response meeting,
that chorus rapid response meeting. But for everything Dan Clancy,
Twitch,
>> every single thing Dan Clancy does. Let me see if I
can find the
I don't see it here. It might have been removed because of how
embarrassing this is.
Let's see here. Uh, past 24 hours. >> Asan is bad, but
bad in like a good way. >> Oh, wait. This isn't the Oh,
it is the same thing. It looks like it got
right? It was It was getting up votes, but it just got >> Oh,
that's good. That's a good sign. They feel some shame >> or
maybe maybe hidden. I'm not sure. >> Whatever it is, they
feel some shame. >> They do feel Well, yeah. I don't or
at least that's
there's something there, but I don't see a message saying it's
removed, so I don't know. It got 96% upvoted. I don't know how
something 96% upvoted doesn't get uh any traction at all. It's
a little weird. I don't understand. >> You see a couple
responses, though. >> Yeah, that interview was just Taylor
Ren being a Twitch water carrier. >> What What interview
is he talking about? >> The fact that interview happened
at Hall shows how deep Dan Clansancy is in the deranged snarker
fear. Okay, so this person did this person knows they didn't
watch the interview. They're just just it happening. How dare
these people talk to each other and post the evidence. >> Yeah,
they're just upset that it occurred at all. Listen, listen, maybe
maybe I don't think it will come out that uh Taylor Lens was
like, you know, crazy and being like, "This is your fault. This
is all your fault, Dan. Have Why haven't you said I don't think
she'll do that?" Which is what these people would need to say.
It's not a softball interview, but like why not just wait? Oh,
can you share the link to the interview or where you found it?
I thought it wasn't being released until Wednesday and then this
post gets
interesting. Very interesting.
All right. All right. All right. All right. Oh, unsurprisingly,
another Destiny account. No way. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. J919.
Let's just Let's just take a look and just see the the history
real quick.
Will their post history be available or will they set their [__]
to private? Oh, here it is. Uh, H3H3.
No, this is all H3H3 stuff.
I This guy said this is a Destiny poster. I don't know, man.
>> Man, you can't trust any of these.
>> That's all H3H3 stuff. Okay. Okay. Never mind. There's
a Playum 5. In terms of e economy crashes in history, how does
this one compare to 1929? This is uh 6 months ago. A DD subreddit.
>> Somebody said comments. Okay. >> Uh Destiny. Oh
no, there's a full page of only r/ Destiny post. Uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
>> Maybe they're one of the ones that made the transition
to H3 to start doing their Hassan bidding over there. >> Uh
something like that. Uhoh.
Why is it every Why is it every time?
Well, have you just considered that you can truly defeat fascism
in America
getting rid of Hassan and Dan Clancy via the H3 subreddit? >> Yeah,
that's how you overcome the right-wing media like
blob that's that's destroying all of America right now by getting
rid of Hassan. >> If you think that that's not how, then
show me a way. If you don't have a better way, if you haven't
defeated fascism, don't tell me I'm wrong.
>> let me try my way. Okay.
I just uh it's um by the way this I just want to make it clear
because it sounds like listen you might you might misunderstand
what we're doing here. Do the laugh.
>> I haven't said >> I've said nothing but satire
this entire >> Oh well I'm just saying that you might worry
that that like we're looking at that we're using it to dismiss
this person's argument. No, we're dismissing the argument on
the basis that he's accusing Taylor Loren of being like a hack
and giving a softball interview without the actual evidence of
that being out yet, right? >> Like that's what's goofy.
That's what's hilarious here. The fact that he's also an r/ Destiny
poster is just a cherry on top. It's just funny. Okay. >> Because
the truth is, what if that was a softball interview?
What if it was? And now all of a sudden if she gets any criticism
for it, she gets to revert back to people calling it a softball
interview before it ever came >> Yeah. She can get the
arrangement here. >> And then it gets to be the whole,
oh, they set the narrative before it ever came out. No one's
ever given it a fair listen and I'm just never going to engage
with those those people and you get to just write them off. >> Yeah.
Which I mean she'll probably do anyway or she would have done
anyway. >> that's why you don't do that. It's much easier
for like third parties to understand what's going on when you
don't have [__] like this happening. People are prematurely
snarking on the other person. Okay, you got to hold the snark,
all right, until it's appropriate, until you actually have the
material to snark on.
>> It's crazy to to prematurely snark like this.
>> The most wellinformed community, by the >> What's
that? >> I'm starting to hate the word snark. Yeah, it's
kind of a kind of a crutch at this point, but listen, we you
can use the you can use the buzz terms of the time. That's okay.
That's allowed. >> that's allowed.
>> The snark ain't kosher. That's kind of >> Okay,
going back to now. I think we're Yeah, we're good with this.
Let's go back to the legal mindset video. >> Joking about
this. Oh, he just sorry we we we did cut off right as he was
about to get to the last point which is intentional infliction
of emotional distress which is post incident handling caused
several se several severe I think he means emotional harm given
her history. So it's like literally the fact that they didn't
see it or something was is something they can be held liable
>> I that's contract here that was breached because it
very well may have been something breached in that contract.
The last one though, and I think this one is the most poignant,
is the post incident handling leading to intentional infliction
of emotional distress. I think a lot of things such as them joking
about this and, you know, otherwise minimizing it. I think that
is absolutely harmful for her given her. >> Okay. But pretend
you're a lawyer. Is there any evidence of that happening or >> All
he does is pretend he's a lawyer. >> Yeah. Like you should
be good at this. Yeah, exactly. >> No, but he's pretending.
So, explain to him what a real lawyer would probably >> Well,
I'm just saying like, how do you how do you prove this? How do
you even form this lawsuit? How could you do anything? It's literally,
she's like, they said they were laughing at me. >> I could
totally understand how somebody who is emotionally like distressed,
uh, emotionally dregulated might hear them laughing about something
and misunderstand,
right? That could easily happen to someone. >> And he's
just out here being like, "Yeah, they they laughed at her. Oh,
he she could sue them. She she can sue for this like immediately."
He's the type of sleas lawyer that would tell his client, "Yeah,
we should pursue this because he's going to get like 200, 300
billable hours from it." >> Yeah.
Yeah. He is that guy. He's just instead of being a sleazy lawyer
for people, instead of, you know, being like an ambulance chaser,
he's actually just like a YouTube ambulance chaser. >> convincing
everybody there's a legal case there when there isn't. >> Yeah.
And does he have like a sponsor that is um that links you to
lawyers? >> I don't think so. Or I've never seen it. I'm
guessing most of those companies would want nothing to do with
Andrew's whole business here, right? That you would if you ran
a legitimate legal thing, you would not want illegal mindset
uh legal mindset showing it. That would be disastrous for you.
>> How did you find out about us? Oh, this lady boy lawyer
on YouTube. >> The lady boy lawyer. Okay. He teach you
how to how to get there, how to move there, and how to find the
lady boy. >> I'm being prosecuted for >> all in one
package. >> You told me you're a good one to go to.
>> Her history with stalkers. She has a long history with
stalkers. It's a known thing for her. And I think failure to
do that, inflicting someone with that emotional distress, and
then taunting them,
adding to that fire definitely makes these viable. So, I think
that if she goes to a lawyer, these are all things they should
look at and consider. Maybe they don't go with all of them. Maybe
they go maybe negligent security and IED, intentional infliction,
emotional distress, but these are all things that I think are
very viable for Emiru. Let's get into This is one that was brought
up by my VTuber lovers. >> I told you. I told you. I told
you. I just All I had to kne. All I had to know is who Legal
Mindset is, what his interests are. It was very obvious right
from the beginning. Okay. Very, very clear. Also, I'm going to
hit play. I need to grab I need to use bathroom and grab some
water. I'll be right back. >> And this is one where Chibi's
event, very beloved YouTuber, Chibi Doie, uh had an event that
was cut short. Uh so, not everybody got to see her. Uh and that's
because they were concerned about safety because guess the line
was too long. But beyond that, they also botched the event in
terms of the wristband. So they gave her a wristband to enter
and they wouldn't actually let her enter. They had to send her
over to the desk to get permission to enter. And at that point
some people have reported she had to unmask herself which of
course for VTubers h which have a very very specific security
and financial interest in remaining uh anonymous. Number one,
obviously, just like all other streamers, their identity, if
they choose to remain anonymous
and put them at risk, put them at massive risk. Uh, but beyond
that, >> oh my god, >> if you're thinking about these
people financially, YouTubers financially, a lot of them base
their entire strategy, their entire monetary strategy on not
being unmasked. So, if
>> what the did
Nemo type in the chat, >> Nemo? People molding over the
diaper furry. Meanwhile, there's like 25 YouTubers with child
avatars. >> Who is the diaper furry? And >> that's
what I told you. Weird diaper guy. No, they weren't at Twitch.
Like the front page of Twitch. >> Yeah, that's the diaper
furry. We still haven't looked into that. I could look into it
at some point. >> No, we don't have to look into that.
>> I didn't know what the [__] they were talking
about. >> I just I think this is hilarious. And what is
This is one of the death nails for Twitch right here is that
this VTuber was mildly inconvenienced. This Vtuber being mildly
inconvenienced is the death nail for Twitch. She had to show
her face to people. They might have some some crazed fan might
have found out she's an ugo and destroyed her life. Okay,
that's like the that's the argument that we have going here is
she was mildly inconvenient. She had to go a little bit out of
her way to go to a different door to get into TwitchCon and then
she almost did Did he say she was forced to unmask or almost?
>> Wait, why did she go to TwitchCon at all if she doesn't
want people to identify her? She was wearing a mask apparently.
So maybe she was like, >> "Why was I on Twitch?" >> I
don't know.
I don't know. No, no, no. It wouldn't be that people find out
she's fat. She's obviously there and she would have been known.
Please go for the diaper for a guy. You know what, Dung Devil?
If you want to get all the diaper fur stuff together, we can
take a look at that a little bit later. Okay.
I'm We could take a look. Very possibly. All >> Is the
diaper over his furry costume or inside? over. Well, technically
when they're a furry avatar, they would be literally the anthropomorphized
like the humanistic animal. >> Wait, he's a VTuber. >> Yes,
it's a diaper furry Vtuber. >> So, it's a drawing. >> Yes.
Of like a tiger or something. I >> he doesn't wear a fursuit
with a diaper over it. >> They might They might wear a
fursuit with a diaper over or under it in real.
We don't see it. >> We don't know. Okay. So, they are a
>> They're a Vtuber. Yes. And people are upset that this
VTuber wears a diaper.
Because they are a child. Like they they're acting like a child.
They have a pacifier, too, I believe. >> But they're a
furry, so they're an >> Yes. Yes.
Uh, are you going to cover Adam Mockler on JLP? Probably not.
I mean, maybe. I mean, probably. I eventually if like the content
gets dry. Probably. If it's good, especially if I hear it's good,
I'll go check it out. But >> eventually we're going to
have cameras because I am actually just making facial expressions.
I don't know what to say. >> Yeah, it's uh it's tough.
It's tough. She did short circuit. She is she is like very confused,
very concerned about the things she's hearing. >> No, Cherry
sees everything wrong with this. Okay. I see everything wrong.
>> No. Yeah, it's No, it's a problem. It's a problem.
>> All right.
>> Yeah. Apparently Adam Mockler, the Midas Touch guy.
Talk to JLP. >> Oh, Jesse Lee. Not okay. No, regular Jordan
Peterson. He's not Jesse Lee or sorry Jesse Lee Peterson, not
Jordan B. >> Okay. Very cool. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> They're
forcing a VTuber to unmask himself to reveal himself. That is
something that could undercut their actual financial stream,
their model. Uh and therefore, I think there could be some financial
damages there as well. So, let's go over. >> This is This
is like the most predictable Queenman take of all time, by the
way. Like I I you could have I wouldn't have to know or have
ever met Queenman. I just That's the most predictable. Like that
is obviously what his take would be. >> This is I don't
ask questions about Cman's dating life. I don't ask questions
about anything like that because I don't want to be able to predict
this >> that Sure. Sure. But that that does No, no, no,
no, no. I'm tell I'm telling you he would have like a coherent
argument for why he thinks the guy's based and he could like
convince people. But I'm just telling you from a base level I
have no idea. Just from a base level, I just knew that Queen
would have taken the diaper for his side for whatever. Like >> oh
because he's like edgy and >> on vibes on vibes. Yeah.
And everybody would have been upset about it. Everybody's like
disgusted about it and Queen would have gone they're so norm.
It's not that bad. >> You're so normie for being like you're
all cringe. You're all >> cartoon diaper. What the [__]
is wrong with a drawing of a cartoon diaper? >> Yeah. And
trust me if you got into an argument he would actually have a
good argument. I don't I don't doubt that. I don't doubt that
people disagreed in his chat and then he was like, "Hop on the
stream and I'll argue with you about this." And he destroyed
them totally. >> I I believe that. Anyway, realistically,
I'm also just like 30% trying to bait Queen onto the stream,
so that's fine. Didn't work. Next time, we'll get him next time.
>> He's not gonna save you.
>> Hassan, this is one I I really find interesting. So,
at the exact >> Okay. Hello.
>> Hello. I do think he should be banned, but um he said
you should hit normies with your car, so that's awesome. >> It
will just be your pain. >> Oh, Jesus.
I thought this was just going to be about the fact that he's
a diaper furry, but he said >> crazy, too.
>> Yeah, he he said uh he was talking about XQC and his
fans, and he said
uh NPC normies are like NPCs, and you wouldn't feel bad hitting
NPCs with your car in Grand Theft Auto. >> Well, you might
not feel bad, but you would build up stars for the cops to come
after you, you know.
>> Well, yeah, true. But >> it's just wrong. Did
he really only get banned for calls to violence though? Like
it wasn't like oh like weird >> he got banned. I haven't
really looked into it. I just saw that was going
>> I haven't really looked into that. >> Yeah, I
have not looked into it either. It just was one of those things.
It fell by the wayside. So lucky you do. You see this legal mindset
video?
Listen
up. >> I saw there existed but >> yeah. Cherry pointed
out your thumbnail for this video like earlier today to me and
uh and you like ruined the start of the video for me with the
thumbnail. Like I literally can't unsee the thumbnail now whenever
I see this guy. >> Like you move his eyes further. >> Lazy
eyes. Yeah. Yeah. When I edit his eyes to be lazier. Yeah. >> Like
I >> I Somebody needs to tell me what animal this looks
like. It there's some sort of reptile
or rodent that looks like this with the eyes.
Is it >> probably a sloth? >> Maybe some type of
lizard.
>> Maybe an iguana or a chameleon. I don't >> I don't
know. >> We'll figure it out. >> All right.
Hey, we're getting through the the death nails to Twitch now.
Hassan, the Hassan death nail is here. >> Oh my god. Maybe
it's a Shih Tzu
dog. >> Okay.
Shih Tzhus do have crossed eyes. That is actually accurate. Same
time this is happening. I've seen several videos of Hassan kind
of hitting his >> about this uh yesterday. And it was like,
"Stay stay strong, Emiru. We're with you." >> And I hovered
over the thing and and the bio had an Israeli flag in it.
And uh I I had I had a bit of a meltdown over it cuz I realized
that everyone's just using this to attack Twitch over Israel.
>> And it's just like,
>> "Oh, did you see >> innocent innocent young way
in front of everyone? This is This is
>> uh No, >> this is actually >> Hold on. Can
you join the presentation wherever you are? >> I don't
know if you're at home or what. >> Wait, before you detour
there, I need to see what he's talking about right now. >> What
he's talking Oh, >> you think people are gonna align this
>> This is This is about This is all about just taking
that It's like another Dan Saltman just line, isn't it? It's
just like all the same people >> going after Twitch for
the exact same reason, which is they they were too nice to the
lefties a few years ago and um they support terrorism.
It's all just in
every other tech platform. Every other major publication in the
US has just been bought up by total pro-Israel
like companies and [__] like you know Larry Ellison
has just bought half the media and >> put Barry Weiss in
charge of like CNBC or whatever the >> and they tried to
shame Anakus Barian for pointing it out. Okay
was right. >> Who is paying them to say this then? Because
if you remember earlier this year, like Morgie is one of the
female creators on Twitch that was just getting preferential
treatment, right? She got a ban overturned in like 12 hours.
It enraged people because most people >> she's mad like
15 times or something. >> So many times. And she got a
ban that has been enforced on her multiple occasions just overturned
in half a day. Like, okay, favoritism is crazy. and she is now
going after her own platform that gives her the golden treatment.
It can't be for free. She has to be seeing a bag somewhere else,
right? >> Well, being with uh being popular, being like
getting eyes on your stuff. Yeah. But I >> No, not being
like she has to be getting a bag or she has to know that the
bag at Twitch is dry. >> That's what it is. Yes. It's the
bag at Twitch is dry. like she she sees the the platform going
down and you're seeing like this is the rats fleeing the sinking
ship and they're just like they're taking a shot on the way out
>> but fleeing the sinking ships now cuz when it was before
when it was train wrecks calling out and they were worried about
ads on Twitch and stuff like that. No, everyone banded together
to protect
>> to make sure it didn't sync. No one's doing that now.
Listen guys, it's our right to have on this 13 plus platform
um our entire and badge hanging out and this little hammer that
lets you hit our Okay, that's our that's our right as Americans.
Oh, now now um No, no, no. Fire Dan Clansancy because Emiru got
assaulted because of her own lazy security and Twitch's bad security.
>> And I don't I don't even see a new hole in the ship
of Twitch.
>> I see the >> Well, there's the perception. >> Exactly.
It's like the perception. There's no new hole, though. They are
actually creating holes themselves.
>> Which is what makes me feel like, are you getting paid?
>> that's problem with Twitch. No, no new holes. No new
holes on Twitch. >> They keep having to censor them.
>> Be the uh if this was all Eddie's minations. Okay. If
Eddie was really behind this, if Eddie was throwing a bag at
Dan to take Twitch out. >> Yeah, we have hags like Emeru
still around. Hags like Emer hanging around. It's been old as
>> 30 years old and you acting like a cat online. What
the [__] you doing? >> She It's more concerning
that she acts like a 10-year-old. That's the concerning thing.
Okay.
>> And the concerning thing is just this time last year,
uh Queen didn't have a problem with how she was acting. It's
all like
in 300 years. Satire. He changed. He changed. >> Oh, we're
going to watch. That's the point I'm getting. >> No. No.
That's not satire. satire in the same way that the uh the ke
stuff was satire for people. No, I don't believe in magic numbers
that change the world. What? Meanwhile, every time they get bumps,
okay, they lose their >> She defends Teone and Asmin to
this day
and that Creamman fell out of love.
It's just that >> that might be it. He can't he can't be
in love with somebody eggs co-host. >> No, I know she'll
come around. I know she'll come around. >> She'll come
around.
>> Hold on. But you got to watch this video. Okay, I've
been talking to Emmer on Telegram this last week. I've bought
a few Apple gift cards. >> Oh, whatever happened to that
guy? That black guy who was dating Pokey. >> He's losing
it. He didn't realize there was no security at TwitchCon. He
realizes he fumbled every opportunity to go and grab grab Pokey
personally. Okay. >> So many years in. >> They've
definitely got Shabbo's face on like uh in like the security
like book or whatever, you know.
>> probably. Yeah, probably.
Okay, I got to I got to play this Morgai clip because I know
it was like raging for me and I didn't really follow any of Morgpai's
stuff with Chud and I I'm aware of the super mega drama. Like
I know she was involved there but like I didn't follow it super
closely. It just wasn't something that was like big. But her
response here, she totally throws Twitch under the bus. She's
totally like on team techone Asmin Gold. It's very >> saw
him at a party that very night. Oh
Oh, we know, man. That Emmy in her video, she's like, "Twitch
staff higherups were seen partying that night."
And as soon as she said that, I was like, "0% chance that was
not Dan Clancy, dude." Cuz all he does is put on his little cowboy
hat and he just wants to go out and party with the streamers.
Dog, you are not cool.
You're as you're cringe as hell and this this
you let this happen. Your your events >> b this hole now.
B this hole now. Dan >> I dude this was so tilting for
me. It's like there's no way. I guarantee when you go back to
like people calling for Dan Clancy's head the first time she's
out here probably defending super caping for him, right? There
has to be stuff logs videos something.
I just know it because obviously the whole joke with Dan Clansancy
for a while was he's a gigoner, right? Who's unbanning all of
these who keep violating the platform to >> Like she is
part of the reason Twitch is considered a joke and their moderation
is considered a joke. She might be the biggest contributing reason.
I would say more than Hassan.
>> Dude, it's it's crazy that she's going this hard on
Twitch where they where they like totally broke their entire
to protect her and people like her. >> Her events
are a show. Your platform is a show. He needs to step down. He
needs to set step down. You are an as you are not the cool CEO.
You are a parasocial viewer
who got a job
and now you think because you have this job that you can
be cozy with these streamers when you're not even doing your
job, right?
You're as you're cheesy as hell, dude.
Dancing with 20some year old girls. >> Why don't all CEOs
just go to Morpai for
>> Why Why don't they all just You can clearly tell someone
doing their job, you know? >> That's the best part. Like
you suck your [__] this pioneered the art of putting
like green screen pants on so you can put gameplay on your ass.
Hey, and beyond that, literally Morg Pie's only the the thing
she's known for most online is just a lack of a gag reflex. It's
like I understand how that could be helpful for Dan Clansancy,
but but I don't think that's all being a CEO is. Okay. If I want
advice on how to learn how to deep throat like the best of them,
I'll come to Morgie. If I want advice on how to run a tech company
or how to be a big contributor to a tech company, I'd probably
go to Dan Clancy.
That's how it is, man. Dude, she they gave her so so
many chances on Twitch and she just stabs them in the back the
second it looks like it would be profitable to do so. That's
wild.
>> And by the way, not that that would be wrong if Dan
Clansancy had done some like e egregious moral wrong, right?
But it's just vibes. They're all running off of vibes. You backstab
this guy on vibes is [__] up. Anyway, I just I knew
I I'm pretty sure if you go and find any of Morpai's previous
statements on this, it's going to be the same thing. And you
see the exact same thing, by the way, that made her pile on the
super mega guys. It's the exact same behavior. Like, oh, these
guys are getting cancelled. Oh, the whole world's against these.
Oh, I can just get in here for free. Yeah, for sure. I'll totally
dog pile on. >> She she outed one of the super mega guys
for ghosting her.
>> that was what it was. And it was like the guy showed
the text and it was like a completely like it was like basically
all discussed beforehand like this is shortterm and all this.
>> He still felt like bad lied about him cheating as well.
Lied about him cheating. That was the other thing like he wasn't
in a relationship at the time. >> Like he was about as
upfront as you could possibly be like literally and it wasn't
even um it wasn't even like he was looking or you know he could
do this. It's possible he's just doing it for plausible deniability
but he's like I'm literally just not in a good emotional place
after breaking up with my girlfriend. I'm not ready for anything.
if you wanted to hang out maybe, but like it wouldn't be something,
right? That's like what he laid out. So, if you take him at his
word, what he said in the text, it's like he's not even saying
like, "Oh, I just want to like and and that's what I do." He's
just like, "Oh, I'm in an emotionally like bad place right now.
I don't think I could be in a relationship."
I don't know. I And then she she tries to pile on and pretend
he cheated on his girlfriend with her.
Oh, boy. She's been banned 11 times and five of those were indefinite.
Yeah. Well, those indefinite suspensions, how long did those
indefinite suspensions last for?
I Hold on. Morgpie,
witch bands. Let's take a look. Let's take a look. What do we
got? Um, unbanned. Do we get indefinite here? Oh, do we not see
indefinite bands?
Well, we can see that none of them went longer than a week.
Unbanned after a day. Unbanned after a day. Unbanned after a
day. Unbanned after a day. 3 days. 2 days. 2 hours. 40 minutes.
7 days. A day. 13 hours. Crazy. Oh, better banned. Hold on. What
is this? Give me more information. Will it say which ones were
indefinite? Oh, yeah. Okay. Banned for an indefinite period.
Okay. So, all of these these five were all banned for an indefinite
period.
3 days, 2 days, 2 hours, 1 hour, 7 days.
Uh-huh. Bro, she sure loved that Twitch moderation when it was
going in her favor, didn't she? She had no complaints, no concerns.
Oh, boy. All right.
Let's uh let's get back to hearing how Hassan is Hassan Hassan
hitting his limit. Needs a streaming break. Do real charity work.
Brother, this guy this guy is proof, okay, that white people
really aren't oppressed. They still have every advantage in the
world because he is running an actual Stardust stream with the
PowerPoint null and he gets massive viewership. Okay, it's a
complete cosmic injustice that Stardust with this exact same
content can't get viewers. Okay,
this is you never need to when white people complain about any
kind of racism against them. All right, just understand that
this guy is doing stardust content and getting 100,000 views
per video. All right, he has no room to complain ever in his
entire [__] life.
I'm going to hit play. I got to grab some caffeine. >> Was
actually watching this guy for legal research on stream last
night. No joke. She was like taking notes on this guy's videos
to learn about the H3 case.
>> H
dude, I am not shocked. I'm not shocked to hear that. Oh >> yeah,
it's just absurd. >> And like I think everybody but Dan
Saltman has come to realize that this guy's just like a total
grifter. He'll just tell you whatever.
>> Dan knows that. No, Dan knows. Dan Dan doesn't think
realize anything.
>> What do you think of the concept that this guy's basically
like an ambulance chaser telling you you have a case, but it's
just for YouTube. It's just for like the drama sphere. like he's
he's the guy who comes along and needs the billable hours. So
he uh he just tells you you have a case. He makes up whatever
he can. >> That's really bad, guys. That's really bad.
They really >> you could be you could be entitled to compensation.
It's it's crazy how he'll just figure out how to say that like
you have the legal right to sue somebody and there's just no
basis for it. No reason to think that that could be possible.
He just wants the billable hours. Uh Asmin and Techone like this
guy. I'm sure they do. They all suck each other off in Twitter
comments all the time. He's signed to mythic talent.
>> Oh, sick.
They got rid of Asmin. Go. Sorry. They got rid of Techone. Step
in the right direction. They hired this guy. Two steps back.
Okay. One step forward, two steps back.
Unlucky. Here. I got to grab some caffeine. I'll be right back.
I'm just going to hit. >> At the exact same time this is
happening. I've seen several videos of Hassan kind of hitting
his limit where he's saying, "I'm just tired of streaming. Nothing's
working. You know, no change, no real change is happening." You
see him out here with his dog and he's walking wearing a bulletproof
vest with a press uh label on it. a press chevron on it, walking
around a very very peaceful city. Um, and people are obviously
pillarating him for that. Uh, I will say this and I am obviously
taking a different route and I've you've seen this with a lot
of my coverage of, you know, Somali Vitali where even the people
that are my en
are people actually pillaring Hassan for this or is this just
like the same group of people that are always literally any image
of Hassan just makes them see
That son looks awesome wearing the press vest and just Hollywood
whoever is has >> Listen, he's going to get he somehow
he's just very concerned. All right. He's watched a couple of
his friends who were press and weren't wearing their vests get
sniped by the IDF. Okay. And he's just he's going to wear this
vest everywhere when he goes as far as we're watching like um
black people fighting videos and like gang gang shootings on
Twitter. Okay.
So he started going in the press fest. It's racist material.
You think this is his own neurosis at play here right now?
>> LA's a war zone right now, guys.
>> You know what? Maybe maybe ICE does maybe we do need
the National Guard, actually, guys. Okay, this is a lot of crime.
You can only watch so much Asmin Gold before you start falling
for the propaganda, guys. It happens to the best of us. >> Enemies,
even the people that don't like me, I still say they deserve
a chance. They deserve an option to do good. uh to be forgiven
to you know choose the right >> sorry I'm so Aan was just
training his dog so that he won't react so that it won't react
if it get hits by if it gets hit by a taser is fantastic I'm
sure you stole that from Twitter but thank you very much em choose
the good path even Hassan even Hassan uh I'm willing to look
past all the defamation uh that he's done and say hey Hassan
for the best and I can say this myself having just taken a streaming
break it's one of the best things I did in my life uh to just
take a solid break where I just didn't look at the internet for
several days. That actually was quite good. And one of the things
I did do during that >> Where was he during the break?
He was
He's definitely being held somewhere,
>> A child prostitute probably. I'd imagine. I'd guess
I don't have >> Is that really your response to being held?
God damn it. Okay. Well, we let that one go. We keep rolling
with the punches. Holy. >> I was do some charity work.
I actually gave some uh we helped somebody prepare food and give
it to the less fortunate. I did some donations helping out the
homeless going to the temples here in Thailand. Um >> hold
on. Apparently Dan Dan Clansancy did get caught potentially at
this TwitchCon with a younger girl. >> Have you seen this?
>> You seen this? Are we just going to broadcast propaganda
here? >> Hold on. What is this? It's It's from an
>> Wait. Okay. Please. As long as it's really him doing
something, right? Caught on FaceTime hanging out with a young
girl. Oh, wait. Is this going to be the girl walking into Action
Man's streaming place and it's caught on >> Wait, there's
Dan Clancy. Show me Dan Clancy again.
>> Tell Dan Clancy we said what's up. >> There's
no way.
>> Wait, Dan Clancy. Do you know who I am? Wait, let me
ask. That's literally him. Wait, Dan.
>> Wait, Dan Clancy. >> Wait, was he live somewhere
or was he just Was he just chilling? Dude, that's so based. What?
>> Wait, is that based? I mean, it's
>> I mean, how old is she?
>> 26. She's 26. >> Yeah, that's B. >> Oh,
by the way, this is uh this is a little misleading. A young girl
instead of saying 26.
>> yeah. 26 is not a young girl. >> Yeah, I don't
think that's the I don't think I'm getting called. That's a hag.
Okay. That's a hag.
I'm I'm telling you though with this one that would definitely
be a little weird depending on what the context was. Okay. Dan
Clansancy strikes me as the kind of guy who's like a little bit
he might actually be someone who like you know she added called
him and he just answers because he answers for streamers.
>> I really want to know how many female
feel like if I just flirt a little bit with this dude like my
channel will be >> She's just buying a little a little
band insurance, right? >> Yeah. Oh, Dan, you're so funny.
>> Just a little quick 12-hour
ban overturn.
>> Yeah, exactly. >> How normal is this? >> Is
that Is that really a crime? Is that And is it a crime on Dan's
part to allow that to happen? Probably. Not literally a crime,
but figuratively a crime.
>> dude, I literally just saw Dan Clancy on my soul. I
did. >> Did you see him, mate? I saw this.
>> Jesus. I So then she's got what? Another phone here
with
Oh, wait.
That's No, that's just Dan Clansancy in person. Wait, where were
they hanging out?
Hold on. Was this like at the con or at some official party where
Dan was or is it in like a hotel? >> Airbnb. It's the Airbnb.
>> It's at an Airbnb. Are you saying that for a fact? No,
>> I'm saying that because I'm saying that. Okay, fair
enough. I'm just curious
because I I feel like I feel like I see the framing and I'm immediately
like
I need to look closer. Need to see what's actually happening
here. They in a room closet. I have no idea where they were.
Yeah, you need to know where they are.
That was an actual thing on Instagram. Wait, what? Oh. Oh, someone
girl slept with an IG dev for an unban. Sure, sure, sure. Okay,
we got a Reddit thread as well.
Let me take a look. 27 years old blood nymph.
Young girl, she looks in her 20s. She's nearly 30. Okay. Oh,
is this Listen, removed.
67% upvoted. Okay. Actually, the people are seeing. Okay. It's
just very obviously not like a big deal.
The title makes it sound like she's underageed.
Hold on.
Hold on. Quick check. Quick quick credentials check. Asmin gold
viewer. I'm I'm betting Asmin Gold viewer. Okay,
we got some we got some asmin gold. Oh, somebody posting uh apparently
K-pop nip slips.
So cool.
>> Let's go. What?
>> K-pop nip slips. And then uh I don't see any streamer
com.
>> Oh boy. I don't see I don't see anything for streamers.
All right. This guy's a gooner. I saw a project Melody post.
It's over. That guy's a VTuber viewer. Unlucky. Okay. All right.
I don't
I don't know if there's anything here,
Him right now. Action man clips. She went from Ed Matthews bed
to the Twitch co bed in a day. I don't think that's what happened.
Okay. Well, we'll look for more information at some point or,
you know, just never address this again. One of the two. >> And
once again, I think that's very fulfilling. As son's in LA, they
got Skid Row down there between what is it? Third and seventh,
right? where he could go down there and help the homeless, help
people out. If he wants to do something in line with his socialist
views, he could go start a community garden. He could go pick
up a shovel and start digging and plant some plants, whatever.
I think that would actually do him some good right now rather
than streaming and continuing to dig himself deeper as collargate
is not going anywhere anytime soon. That's going to be going
on for a very, very, very long time. And I think it actually
raises some very interesting questions particularly in regards
to and I do stand by this of hey look you're putting the shot
collar on the dog put the shot collar on Hassan. Someone actually
suggested to me that they do it as an armband or on the dominant
hand or on the wrist. So it shock somebody there if they go to
do an action which would be very very very
>> bro. We got 5 minutes into the video and he's just yapping
about Hassan again and shot
Pavlovian training for somebody who's doing something wrong.
But once again, I think Hassan definitely needs to step back
for a second uh as kind of the profile of a spoiled nepo baby
who's never seen anything real. Uh instead of going out and doing
fashion shoots and
>> it will just be your painting.
Ruben donated $3.
Bro's audio is just out of sync as his eyes. Oh, hold on. No,
the audio is out of sync on the >> Okay, good. Sorry.
>> that [__] annoys me. >> Wait, did
he delete his last video? What? This one or some other one?
>> The mental breakdown one? The one where he had a total
mental breakdown the other day? >> Wait, did he did he
delete it? >> I don't think so. >> Dude, that was
crazy. Did you read the comments on that?
>> I don't know if I read the comments on stream, but the
comments were like literally all Andrew, are you okay? Andrew,
this is up. Andrew, like can you Andrew, do you have friends
who you can talk to right now?
>> Like, oh boy. Okay, hold on.
I was looking for something here. Am I missing? I don't think
>> whatever else he needs to go and actually help people.
And >> oh, I was going to talk about how these guys talk
about the perceptions of Assan. I don't think they realize that
like Hassan has been insulated for like a very long time with
his audience in that like none of these criticisms work anymore
because of how he's been critiqued on other stuff in the past,
right? Like basically they've split everybody. Everybody's so
polarized against like this Hassan critique in his audience that
even if these were valid critiques, I don't think they work.
Like these guys are like, "Oh, legal mindset here. Oh, he's a
Nepo baby. He's got the image of a Nepo baby and it'll never
go away unless he goes and does charity work." It's like, bro,
it will never it never would have gone away from you or for you
in the first place. Like you're you're literally not doing anything.
>> unless he does charity work. >> Yeah, he's he's
sitting there. He's fine. He's sitting pretty. uh 30,000 viewers
again today. I don't know.
I don't know. He was uh Hassan was falling off like a year and
a half ago. He was actually falling off. He they've just made
him like popular again. >> Are you sure? This is just something
that always um
always exists when
I don't know the political climate is not so controversial or
antagonistic. Right. Biden's pres presidency like the second
year it was just a lull. Biden wasn't really causing controversy.
>> Oh, sure. No, this is probably a lot of it. Yeah, >> they
there was no red wave and so things just lulled and they ignored
conservatives for a really long time.
>> Yo, Sha Maloney with the 25
gifties. What's up, Sha Maloney? How's it going? >> That's
right. That's
>> Damn. That's uh some hours. >> I can never say
that enough. Honestly,
>> that's some hours. Holy moly. Thank you very much, Sean.
That's massive. That's huge.
Uh you you might be right though, Cherry, that like basically
after the election season, if Biden had won or Camala had won,
it might have been like a fall-off again. >> No, no, no,
no, no, no. I'm not saying that. If Camala won, this would still
occur. Okay. >> You think so? >> Camala was nobody's
choice. That That's still That makes Republicans mad. that makes
a lot of Democrats mad. Aam a Kamala presidency would not have
meant that um everything remained I don't know tame or whatever.
>> Sure. Sure. Okay. Past four years it looks like he very
very regularly averages around 30,000 viewers but in this end
of 2023 into 2024 era here he was dropping way below that. He
was like >> there was nothing to cover for politics. He
was trying to go on the beach in Australia and off at his Discord
for you guys. I'm just trying to do normal things. Why won't
you watch? >> Dude, I got that totally. It's It's actually
so annoying to me sometimes where you've like covered something
twice on stream and somebody's like somebody comes to you and
they're like trying to, you know, you're annoyed. He was annoyed
at his low viewership and the person is like, "Have you considered
going to the beach and having fun? >> What the [__]
is Yeah, that's what he did. That's what he's complaining about."
I'm like, "Dude, I have total empathy for that." When somebody's
like, >> they're like, "Hey, have you considered this?"
It's like, yeah, the thing I just >> Oh, man.
>> listen. I understand him being upset about that. Okay,
>> that was funny. But that was like the bottoming out
for Hassan. And then he he had a comeback with the election season.
>> yeah, the worst thing for Hassan is that he goes to
the beach and only 9,000 people watch.
>> That's that's what it is. Okay, Hassan, by the way,
that's depression for Hassan. When only 9,000 people watch him
at the beach, he he approaches depression. That's what his life
is. Crazy stuff. Little did he know we actually don't watch him
on mute >> going out and doing fashion shoots and GQ or
whatever else he needs to go and actually help people and maybe
he'll be more fulfilled and maybe he'll actually, you know, go
down a better path. But of course, we could only hope, right?
We could only hope. Now, let's go here with moderation. This
is a big one and this is one that I'm very interested in particularly
as I think it's heading down the Roblox uh route essentially
because with recent tests which I've seen uh others run on Twitch
with starting a new channel and trying to stream whatever including
very vile content that would not be acceptable on most other
major platforms. Stuff that would get you banned immediately.
Well, all of that stuff bypassed the filters. All that stuff
got on Twitch without any moderation. And the big issue that
appears to happen is Twitch appears to lack any automated moderation,
relying on manual moderation. The problem with that with purely
manual moderation, particularly if it's not getting the most
vile stuff, is number one, you're >> what is the most vile
stuff that doesn't get caught?
>> You might
getting people to push on Twitch. Is that what I'm hearing? >> I
assume he's talking about like uh what do you call like do you
remember the Buffalo shooter, the guy who shot up that supermarket?
I think that was on Twitch, wasn't it? I feel like stuff like
that, not having automated is where that stuff will get you because
there's like two people watching and even those two reports might
not be enough to get in front of a mod very quickly. It's like
Twitch does require manual. >> Happens on Facebook Live
too. Like >> well, but it's like what is the issue? You
understand that if somebody only has two viewers and there's
nobody reporting it, then no crime is occurring. If a tree falls
in the forest and nobody's there to hear it, it doesn't really
make it. You don't know if it makes a sound, right? It's like
>> Also, doesn't it take time?
Have you ever been one of those people who does at Grock and
it doesn't reply right away and you're like, "Oh my god, did
I do it wrong?" And then it replies like in five minutes or something.
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> Yeah. I mean, manual or sorry, automatic moderation
could take time. I think it's I don't think they have anything
like that, but I think YouTube are the only it's the only platform
with that. I think essentially nobody else has anything beyond
maybe transcription >> and YouTube has it to the point
where it definitely has flaws and now they're like considering
rolling out a program on how to overcome all of the auto moderation
that they don't have the manpower to overturn and like
>> Yeah. Yep.
Yep. So,
and hopefully whatever that is, hopefully that will affect my
stuff soon. YouTube spent a lot of money to make content ID.
They did. Yes. It is. It's like an incredibly complex system.
That's again the one place I agree with Devon Nash is Twitch
had a ton of money. They they were flushed with cash. They could
have gone down that route trying to figure out how to do like
automated realtime video moderation and they didn't do it and
it's now [__] them and they'll never get the money
to invest to go build that platform out again. we might go for
a very long time with a total YouTube like super majority in
terms of monetizable video platforms because they when when cash
was cheap, they spent all of the money to go and research that,
figure it out and and make it. Although at the same time, you
got to figure I guess as technology gets better. Uh maybe it'll
just be a lot easier to implement, right? I think the rule is
what every every
is it I thought I think it's like 5 years things get twice as
easy as like there's a rule of thumb something like that. So,
>> nobody wants you back on YouTube more than me. So, we
can get rid of that stupid ass cartoon drawing and you can finally
go on camera cuz that >> it's just so ugly. >> That'll
totally happen.
No, it will actually happen. >> It looks so stupid.
>> Can I It's literally the lo. Can you not Can you not
like totally >> You have a cartoon with dick sucking >> Okay.
I You know
You know
You know >> you got DSL. >> No. No. appreciation.
No appreciation. >> Fat on camera, though. Let's be real.
>> I have, by the way, I have the recording of me and Queen
on our first call on on video camera and him going seeing me
and going, "Ah, I don't care. I'm still going to call you fat."
Okay. He's lying right now. He's full of And one day that video
will become relevant. All right.
He's full of it. He's full of it. >> You're letting a lot
of stuff that clearly breaks TLS ug.
Ah, you never know. If you're fat enough, it would be better
to have the cartoon picture >> is number one, you're letting
a lot of stuff that clearly breaks to pass. But beyond that,
you're actually engaging in discriminatory moderation. So, some
are punished severely, some are punished a very long time. You
call somebody fat, you're out for, you know, a month, whatever,
right? Whereas others are not punished at all. They're given
a pass. This is something that leads to a massive danger for
regulatory action. That is states taking action. And especially
if this dangerous content is getting out there to people that
are minors, which is a massive part of the Twitch uh the Twitch
ecosystem.
>> This is one of those things that I feel like people
at Twitter for as well where they they take content that they
didn't like and they super like hardcore deboost it like that
this was their approach was they shadowban people. They deboost
like really offensive content and then people go, "Yeah, but
kids could look at it." It's like but a kid can't organically
get to it ever. Like it literally gets deboosted. It's not actually
a problem. you're describing a problem that doesn't really exist
>> and it doesn't matter. People just don't care, right?
The fact that it's like accessible in some way just breaks people's
brains. And so the same thing here. It's like, okay, if there's
some really disgusting content going on on Twitch, if any amount
of people are seeing it, it will be reported and it will be dealt
with. But it's only the cases where people aren't seeing it where
you objectively shouldn't be mad that failed to get reported
and handled. But if there's like a lot of people looking at your
channel and you tell them, "Hey, you could find this really like
obscene content that like, hey, miners really shouldn't be looking
at it."
You kind of signal boost it.
>> Yeah. The the YMS. >> Yeah. You like >> That's
the YMS conundrum. >> You create awareness to it. Especially
if you're the type of person who
I'm sorry, he likes cartoons.
I don't care what you guys call it. Shodakon or anime, weeb,
manga, >> those are words. >> You guys, you guys
like cartoons and so do children. >> That should be, by
the way, if you are actually like some traditional values person,
that should be your position. By the way, okay, there we cannot
allow any of these
anime fan trad people to exist anymore. It's just so fake. It's
so phony. All right. If you're going to present yourself as traditional,
you're you are like the the Greek warrior or something, stop
watching anime. Shut the [__] up. Otherwise, okay?
You cannot you cannot square the circle on these two things.
You can't put them together. They don't fit.
So, if you look at the Roblox regatory action, you could see
very similar stuff happening on Twitch because they know this
is an issue. They very well know this is an issue and they're
just choosing to ignore that. So, my conclusions here are Twitch
is facing all of these issues at once. And because they're facing
all of these issues at once, once again, they're not it's not
going to happen tomorrow. It's not going to happen next week.
But this can be the death spiral for Twitch. This could be as
they go down or as they get hit. And what could happen? Well,
of course, you also have parent company Amazon, which was just
cyber attacked likely due to their over reliance on AI by Amazon
Web Services that just happened today, right? You could have
a lot of that stuff maybe is going to be automated. Maybe AI
is going to take over. But of course there's problems with that
as you see without you know a human uh link in that chain it
can be kind of sloppy. It can miss things. It can overregulate
and I think the time is right for lawsuits right now regulatory
action replacement of Twitch leadership aka Dan Clansancy. So
I think the time is right for all of these things and I think
we should continue to monitor it very very closely because it's
right for >> I he hasn't actually laid out a lawsuit. It's
like, okay, which the question should be for his comments should
be, which one of these lawsuits would you contribute your money
to, right? Which one would you actually contribute money to?
Emiru emotional distress with no evidence. You want to throw
your money behind that? Be my guest, I guess. I don't I have
no idea what the This guy's just out of his mind. It's it he
needs more time. Okay, he was not gone long enough. He needs
more time off. >> All of these things. And I think we should
continue to monitor it very very closely because I think there
will be action. Emaru definitely should bring a claim. Uh definitely
should try something against Twitch. There's no reason not to
at this point and there's more than enough basis for her to bring
that on one of those calls of action. But I want to know what
you guys think in the comments below. Let me know if you like
the fast facts. If you're glad I'm back, uh hit the like button
and I will catch you on the next one. >> The next one.
Okay.
All right.
Um, we got one more. We got a techone video.
Now, are you gonna have to peace out if I watch this techone
video, Queen? Are you going to like chill, do something else?
>> Uh, yeah. I'm playing Digimon, so >> Okay, that's
fine.
I just wasn't sure cuz I'm pretty sure you're going to cover
this on stream most likely, right, >> Probably not. >> Probably
not. Fair enough. Techone is furious. Medatron,
they're lying to you. Listen, this is the last drags of the Twitch
stuff, okay? Save this for a pallet cleanser later. Wait, what
is it? What is it? I literally don't care. I I Stephen Jillian,
I hope you understand. You guys wanted me to stop covering the
Hassan dog collar. I've totally stopped. You can't link me just
random [__] you want to watch about the Hassan dog
collar thing. Okay, it's such a funny song. I'm sure I will really
think it's a funny song and not think that you deserve to be
called from the herd, okay? Called from the rest of humanity
when I watch it. I'm sure that'll be my reaction. No, there is
no
no content that we're going to review unless they donate money.
>> Not even a song. >> Steven Jian got money. He
can't do that. >> Somebody can donate for Steven Jellyon
if you guys want to play the song. >> It's actually a AI
song. You need to be in the street dragged out of your home and
in the street. >> Oh boy. >> Hold on, guys. Um, little
side note before we get in here. Uh, I'm not choosing to make
the videos on my phone over and over again. Um, my PC setup is
almost done. Um, I've had renovations going on in my house pretty
much non-stop since I moved in. It's Oh my god. Yeah, things
are going along smoothly. I'm in Ontario. >> I think I
was about uh gone.
Jesus,
>> old times. I'm getting old, guys. I'm 31. Uh, anyways,
uh the world is shifting for a much worse direction in my opinion.
And uh me being angry at things that uh you know is now considered
the status quo is probably no surprise to you guys. But there's
a lot of liars out there. It's uh it's pretty surprising. I I'm
really I'm really not going to lie. I mean um you know I mean
you see streamers like Valkyrie lying for Hassan. You see QT
accidentally telling the truth uh for Hassan, which was hilarious.
You see porn stars like Sasha Gray lying for Hassan. Then she'll
see the clip of Fant doing the exact same thing that he said
that he didn't do. And then Sasha Gray will be so scared she'll
just close the clip because god forbid she consumes information
that goes against her beliefs, which we're going to get into
a whole bunch of cognitive dissonance later and explain to you
guys what that means for anybody who doesn't know.
>> he just learned that word yesterday. >> He just
learned that explaining the latest word he looked up on Wikipedia.
So guys, cognitive dissonance is like when you think that something
but it's like wrong.
>> No, he didn't even look it up. He got an email of talking
points, okay, >> from somebody.
God, I It's tough, man. It's tough slogging through these videos,
okay? You guys have no idea how correct I just learn every day
how correct Hassan was, okay? How draining it is to be a streamer.
You got to sit here and pretend to care about anything Tech says
beyond just feeling total disgust watching his face.
It's It's rough. Okay. It's rough out here. >> Yeah. And
then we have Assad lying about 108 times. I think that's the
number. 108 times in four days. I believe is the number that
everybody was counting about how many lies. He just looked towards
his audience and said, "Hey, this thing that you saw happened
on camera, it didn't it didn't happen." It wasn't me. She even
got you on camera. Wasn't me. All right, dude. Uh, yes it was.
Um, yes it was. If you were that woman in that music video, I
don't know if you guys are old enough to know that song. If you
were that woman in that video, my god, you were I mean, Jesus.
Anyways, uh, that really is the status quo of what's going on
on Twitch and what's going on with the media. um with other news
sites showing the >> Oh, please, for the love of God, go
on Taylor Loren's, please. >> No kings protest happening
with footage from 2017 in a completely unrelated protest trying
to make it seem like this whole no kings protest was a lot more
successful and larger than what it is. We have >> You have
the info on this? >> Uh I don't have the info on this.
It's very interesting. Have you seen the the video of the No
King's uh protest march?
>> It looks very like organized and stuff like that and
people are trying to say that it's not the accurate footage.
>> Well, it might not be. I haven't looked into it at all.
I have no idea. But I would say I hope Jack has equal hatred
for the people who are taking the Portland stuff using old Portland
videos to make Antifa look crazy. Right. >> But the time-lapse
video of the known king march is accurate and it's like this.
I think it's a photo that was posted of like um something else
that they're trying to say this is the real one. Quan, do you
know better or have you follow? I think I heard um
Pisco and
Hutch and everyone talking about some live and learn and I think
they were saying there was like a live an MSNBC live feed that
was like faked or some there's like a bunch of like conspiracy
theories about how oh the media the media is actually saying
that no so many people here but there was actually no one just
that endlessly
>> pull up this is like the few times I'll tell you pull
up Erdite's Twitter I think she had a good quote tweet of uh
[__] that's like the only time I'll ever say that.
Stop. Okay. It's like a a quote tweet of people saying
like reacting how people are just upset that the protest was
fine. >> That'll be this one then. Refuse to believe people
are actually spending their Saturdays protesting. How many of
these no king protesters? No kings protesters are being paid.
Oh, that's >> It's hers. I'm talking about hers. >> Oh,
she probably replied, right? >> No, no, it should be her
quote. Did you scroll down? Oh, I didn't. When would this be
from? October 18th. >> It's got like four million views
on it or something. It's >> Oh, this one. Oh, why is manga
so mad that the protests were orderly? Oh, >> and just
like that, they're gone. No
Oh, is it just the video
one? Hold on.
>> Sorry. I'm unorganized. This is my
>> Listen, I stick to the docket. Okay. I This is what
happens when I just try to go off uh to flow. Actually, this
isn't what happens. Usually, I can find the
>> It's okay. We're going to clip this moment where I complimented
Aerodite.
>> you tried. You tried. Oh, look. I can find no actual
evidence of the the compliment I just did. Hold on. Maybe this.
Just give me a second. The real stock mom.
Let's check it out. As if you didn't hate the media enough, this
video is from 2017.
People across the country marching as we speak against the policies
of President Trump. This is Boston. Look at that. We'll continue
to follow these rallies throughout the day here on >> Okay,
readers add context. Misleading. This is the No Kings rally from
Boston on October 18th, 2025. NBC 10 Boston has the same aerial
shot. You can clearly see the stage and soundboard are in the
exact location. Also from NBC Oh, so it's just the 2017 rally
aerial footage is completely different. Okay, so just a lie.
Just a lie that sewing about. >> I got it. I'm DMing it
to you now. It was a
It was one of those other plastic
>> You know, the people who are like in politics and you're
like, "Where did they come from? Why do they all look the same?
Why are they all carbon copy white
>> Sure. Sure. >> Same thing, just slightly less
funny than each other. >> Yeah. So, this is a time lapse
from
>> The one they're saying is edited is from Boston, it
looks like. We pulled that one up. And this one's from Chicago
of like a real video as well.
In the middle of October, are the deciduous trees all covered
in green leaves in Chicago right now? Oh, you guys really are
in some serious denial.
Wait, Ian Carol's literally saying, um, he's literally saying
this is fake. I mean, we literally see yellow on the trees. We
see the trees yellowing. Well, no, not that one next necessarily,
but this tree is like pretty yellow. It looks like stuff's starting
to turn for fall right now. I'm guessing that things are slightly
warmer for unknown reasons. >> You could literally just
go to this to this exact location and look at the color of the
trees and see
Oh, was this >> Dude, it's uh
getting dire getting bad. >> Man, that silly serious video
so good. >> It's pretty good. Yeah. >> Hard in times
like this. >> Yeah, we'll have to watch it in a little
>> Critter is lying. >> So, it seems like Teeone
is just lying here. other news sites showing the No Kings protest
happening with footage from 2017 and a completely unrelated protest
trying to make it seem like this whole no Kings protest was a
lot more successful and larger than what it is. We have content
creators lying. We have the new >> So yeah, NBC Boston.
Is this going to be a live feed from a couple days ago? His tattoo
looks so bad. I keep thinking there's a lobster or a crab on
his
>> So, Thousands Turn Out in Boston.
Let's see here.
Also from NBC 10 Boston. I I should look at these instead of
just like skipping through cuz
they're using the same camera footage took the stage and then
certainly looks to be the exact same place. Okay. And then let's
just take a look at the 2017 footage.
These aerial views of the crowd uh counter protest. This is some
2017 footage that was being used. Maybe this is like totally
different. >> I don't even know why they have to why do
they have to have this angle where it's like, "Oh, that's fake
footage. Your protest was unruly or whatever." Or you didn't
have that many people out there. Why don't you just brag about
how you didn't anybody at our protest? You have a W somewhere.
Why? >> You could actually turn this into a W. Why are
you like >> Why do you have to lie?
>> I don't know. I don't know. I just I find it bizarre
that >> maybe they're not sure if they someone at these
things or not. >> Well, I I have no idea. But with Techone,
I just don't understand where he's like, it should matter, right?
It should matter that he's trying to present himself as the guy
who's like looking into this stuff and he's so blackpilled by
the truth and he just lies repeatedly. It should matter to somebody
somewhere.
>> No, it doesn't. >> I need it to matter. Okay.
I need to not need to not think humanity is doomed right now.
And watching Teone, that'll do it to a person. >> There's
no expectation of Teone whatsoever. Not even to be informed.
Asmin Gold has already primed everyone to believe. Teone is what
he is. He's an extremist right now. Teone's falling off. And
it's all Msk's fault because Misk said, you know, he's a loyal.
He's kind of like a weirdo.
This is what happens when you get >> I can't believe Yeah.
I can't believe Mskov lied about Teeone and said he was like
a weird degenerate or like somebody who like liked kids made
comments about kids. That's totally >> That's totally beyond
the pale anything I know about Teone.
>> That's so
Wait, that fits with everything I know about. >> What did
he say about that 8-year-old girl's feet? He wanted them in his
mouth. Wait, what?
>> Who's lying? And even more so, and this one I really
really had to process because deep down and I and I want to make
this very clear.
I don't like being right all the time. It sucks. Um I'm
>> Have we had one moment where Team said something correct?
>> He really did it to himself. Okay.
>> All the time. It sucks. Bring me >> I don't like
being right all the guys. I don't like this >> any joy
to be right because the things that I'm talking about are bringing
me great frustration.
And the thing that I was very frustrated about is even worse
than the news cuz we already knew that was bought. Um, now Twitch
themselves are looking at you in the eye as a consumer and insulting
your intelligence and saying, "Hey, that thing that happened
on camera didn't happen." Now, what am I talking about here?
In case you don't know, Emu uh got assaulted at a con. And a
lot of people are trying to just say, "Ah, well,
it was it was only a kiss. It was literally nobody literally
99.9% of people are going, "Oh, it's like that that happened."
I haven't seen a single person who looks at that. Not even
Yeah. I don't know who said this. I want an example. Okay.
And trust me, if people are saying this, I feel like it's going
to go I have to go to like Andrew Wilson comments or something
along those lines. It's going to be all people techone now aligning
himself with
Like there's just nobody saying that. >> There's only a
Veto say in response to him because I don't think Veto knew >> Veto
Oh no. Veto, sorry, never mind. Nobody's serious. Veto said uh
I think he said that it was overblown. >> He said it was
overblown. Didn't
>> she was only trying He was only trying to kiss her.
I say this because points out if you criticize Techone anywhere
ever, if you say his name, you at him, he will read it. It will
live in his head rentree. This video, this could be him talking
to Veto and like only Veto right now. >> Oh, you think
so?
I think Veto Oh, but Veto did quote tweet. Veto did quote tweet
him. Yeah, I didn't I didn't even think about that. >> Yeah,
let me go find this tweet. Yes, this one. Some weirdo tried to
hug her.
This is This is like the only one. This is literally who he's
responding to.
>> Some weirdo tried to hug her and was immediately stopped
by security. How much drama can you possibly milk out of this
nothing story? >> He didn't even mention the kiss. I think
Veto doesn't even know that he tried to kiss her. Veto is [__]
>> Veto is just rage baiting right now. And that's what
I thought. >> He's kind of spitting. He's kind of spitting
though. Let's be real. Like obviously overblown fully accurately
describing the story but the sentiment's right. The sentiment's
fine. >> It's overblown but it's not overblown by Emiru
or at least not without significant egging on from people around
her. Like it's like people do feel bad for Emirou like that happening
or whatever. You could easily empathize with her. I just don't
empathize. >> I can't even watch her like cuz it's like
I literally can't watch his poke for like more than 3 seconds.
>> What do you mean? It's the She's This is character growth.
She's sticking up for herself for like the first time.
>> you're going to tune out now. >> What Queim means
is he needs Emir to be dancing with her like midrift showing
if he's going to listen. >> That's facts. Yeah, >> he
can listen to her talk. >> Why don't you use Tik Tok? Why
you Why don't you use some [__] Tik Tok? >> I'm
just I'm just saying I feel like I could go to your stream and
see you watching like her Tik Tok or something. Then you're like,
"Oh, her statement, her words. No thank you. Gross." >> Tug
and a forced kiss. Like she didn't die. The point is is that
she could have the point is that she could have been very fatally
wounded or or worse if there is something she could have been
eaten. I think I'll all be wrong. Out of all the crimes, >> it's
really funny because I think this was um this was absolutely
something that got discussed when ISIS was a thing and they were
doing like random indiscriminate terror attacks around the world
was everybody had this conversation. And Teto must have been
totally checked out in a goonfueled stuper just somewhere in
Canada, drugged up off to little girl drawn pictures. Okay. Um
but everybody had this conversation about hey if there's like
people motivated to hurt someone. It's really difficult to stop
that in a like western free like liberty based democracy, right?
It's actually very difficult to stop somebody who wants to hurt
you so badly that they're willing to go get in a truck and drive
through like a Christmas parade or something, right? Like it's
you you would have to live in a society that's so draconian to
prevent that from happening. Right? So he could say, "Oh, the
fact that they let this happen at all, it's like, okay, but to
prevent all >> all individuals who are who have nothing
to live for from doing damage if that's what they want to do
that you you have to go so far to actually like produce or or
to make that happen." Like he's just talking about how it's it's
totally unacceptable we live in a world like this. And it's like
I I don't know. Unfortunately, you you start having to accept
some of these things if you want like a freely flowing con where
people can go meet creators. >> Unfortunately, we do live
in a society.
>> The point is that she could have been very fatally wounded
or or worse if there is something I maybe she could have been
eaten. I think I'll be real. Out of all the crimes in the world,
I think cannibalism is the worst. I think that's the number one
worst crime. I feel like if you've eaten somebody, if you like
Anyways, this is a topic for another day. Um, >> how do
I get stop? >> The thing is >> I'm I'm shutting the
Twitch stream off. I'm going to start saying some stuff that's
not going to let me stay on that platform. Uh, guys, we're going
to kick Only for the rest of the stream. Head over to kick kick.com/jc
if you're watching on Twitch right now. We'll be over there.
Have a good night. Rest of the stream over on kick. All right,
we'll see you guys in just a little bit. >> Actually, don't
think that's true. I just make way more money streaming on kick
only. So,
I don't I'm not really going to say anything to uh violative.
All right, we're good. We're good. Let's continue.
something much worse could have happened and security counter
measures should have been taken and disciplinary actions should
have been taken and well you know Twitch you you did give the
guy a big 30-day ban I want to remind you that a guy who went
up to Emiru and assaulted her got a 30-day ban where Robb
>> again this 30-day ban thing they're running with this
and it's like I know he got a 30-day ban but I've and maybe maybe
we need to hear from Emiru's manager. And this is, by the way,
why you should like confirm things and be pretty trepid you should
move with trepidation when you're trying to highlight stuff like
this. Cuz if Emir got something wrong and you're all blowing
Twitch up for something she got wrong, that's going to be that's
going to blow back on Emirou, right? And to me, when they say,
"Oh, they're only going to do a 30-day ban for this guy." It
sounds like they maybe got his name tag and they banned him for
30 days while they discussed what happened and wanted to see
footage. That seems like the most likely scenario to me. They
didn't look at it and go, "Oh, well, you know, he only tried
to grab her face and kiss her 30 days instead of indefinite."
I just can't see that, man.
Maybe, but I'm don't have this like comically evil vision of
Twitch in my head. So, in my head, I'm like, "Oh, no. They probably
just did this temporarily until they could figure out exactly
what they were doing." But even if that comes out now, it'll
never be clarified. None of these people ever go back and fix
it. >> Joked about beating someone up at TwitchCon and
he got banned for 30 days. a joke got the same banned as a [__]
crime. Um, I want to remind you me calling denims a [__]
and frog and fat got me banned in total for 30 days. Uh, I want
to remind you that Mike from PA literally put a bounty on Destiny's
head and he did not get banned for 30 days. He didn't even get
punished. I want to remind you that Sean dei
>> uh I do think probably Twitch really should have actioned
on those. I think I think Twitch this is probably the only case
where they really well I this is one of the cases where they
really up. They should have actioned on the actual calls to violence.
Having no action there is a little absurd.
Sean to DEI. Yeah. Sean to DEI. I didn't even I didn't even clock
that. >> That's crazy. literally put a bounty on Destiny's
head and he did not get banned for 30 days. He didn't even get
punished. I want to remind you that Shawn the Dei sorry Shawn
the Black
literally said he was going to murder Destiny and how he >> it's
like that's
>> he's just playing the stereotype. Why you got to be
white with bad tattoos and wearing a wife beater? >> Bald
shaved head. Yeah, he is. He is playing stereotype bingo. He's
about to hit it.
I
Yeah, hold on. Wait. Babka's actually got it. All right. Babka's
got it. He should just say the That's what he's That's what he's
going for, right? And he's already said, "Oh, I should be able
to say the fler on Twitter or sorry, on Twitch." He can't say
the He's basically got multiple videos crying in a closet. He
cannot.
>> He's got a video of him crying in a suit, too. >> He
needs to stop himself from finishing the phrase DEI
and keep pushing. He >> should be brutally slaughtered.
And he didn't even get banned. Um, as well as Hassan calling
for the death of many different people and he also did not get
banned. Are we starting to notice a problem? Now, we're going
to go a little bit further. So Twitch put out a notice saying,
"Well, guys, we permanently banned them." Not their decision,
by the way. That was because it was called >> Is Tee really
going to actually take the uh the position that
assaulting another streamer should lead to your perma ban from
a platform? I feel like Tee is the last person, you know, at
least in his own interest, who should be making this
Like realistically, he's got he's got actual allegations against
him that he has lied about having exculpatory evidence for,
right? Not a good sign. He totally dodges the video calling him
out for it. Is he really the guy who should be making this argument?
Is he going after his own bag?
Caught on camera. The clip blew up. Emaru's manager, God bless
their soul, held them accountable and said, "You are going to
take these disciplinary actions and you are going to permanently
ban this loser."
And so they have they put in a note saying the person was apprehended
and is currently being dealt with by the authorities. No, they
weren't. Okay. No, they weren't. And the reason why we know they
weren't is because we literally saw footage of this guy lacadasically
walking at a very relaxed pace out of TwitchCon with nobody
nobody restraining him because just like the last security guard,
well, if you do your job properly, you're going to lose your
job promptly. Uh, welcome to Twitch.tv. Uh, it's great. I also
love how many of your employees I talk to Twitch that even think
that you yourself are because you aren't allowing your own employees,
your own moderators to do their jobs. And even they are like
ah this guy doesn't understand. Nobody here has anything. Why
is there not a single lawyer who like works in California could
come out and go actually this is how liability goes when you're
like renting a venue? Have we really not gotten that video yet?
Cuz hold on. They're saying Twitch said he was apprehended. Where
did Twitch say this? I actually can't see the part where Twitch
said this,
right? I I can't see anything where they're saying he was apprehended.
I need to Somebody link me the article. I feel like maybe a blog
post. >> Assad Denims and all these people are actively
slandering all these people.
But you called him fat. All right. So, you're going to get banned
for two weeks. And now what are we going to do for you?
We're just going to tell you to ignore them because for some
reason the higherups at Twitch are protecting these bozos. Uh,
>> it was in that statement that people were spreading
on Twitter. Wait, the the original Twitch statement. It definitely
wasn't there. I went and looked at this. Was this edited? Maybe.
No. Um, in line with existing TwitchCon security protocols, we
were displayed in this yesterday was extremely distur uh unacceptable
and deeply upsetting. Line with existing TwitchCon security protocols,
law enforcement and event security were on site and responded
to the incident. We immediately blocked that's not apprehended.
We immediately blocked this individual from returning to TwitchCon
prem the TwitchCon premises. They are banned indefinitely from
Twitch both online and inerson events. We are coordinating with
the impact creator impacted creators team and per our standard
protocols continue to cooperate with any law enforcement investigations.
This doesn't say he was apprehended. Where's the like people
are just making up what was said.
That wasn't the first one on Twitter, but yeah, it wasn't in
that one either. Oh well, I'm just looking for like where this
is I'm looking for where they're talking about. >> Yeah,
it's a lot of fun. Keep going. >> So, Twitch literally
put out a public statement that is completely falsified. It is
a complete lie. It was debunked in
None of them put out an apology. None of them corrected the wrong
they did. They looked you in the eye. >> So, Teone believes
the outcome for lying to people needs to be correcting yourself
publicly and apologizing. I would say correcting yourself on
all of the platforms. That that feels to me like it would be
the requisite, right? The prerequisite. It needs to be on the
same platforms with the same visibility as the original thing
cuz this is this is crazy that he's going out and doing this.
Oh, Twitch lied and they need to correct the record now and he
goes out and lies about doesn't ever correct the record. I never
see this guy correct the >> They spit in your face and
they said, "Hey, you're going to believe this
Guys, I mean this on my whole soul on everything. There are so
many people lying to you. It is insane.
I highly
>> and other content creators from their side won't tell
you to do this. I
>> highly,
highly recommend that you approach everything that you consume
with a degree of skepticism.
I highly recommend that you look for proof or
for anything that you hear.
so important because there are so many people looking at you
in the face and lying.
It is insane. And by the way,
dude, this is a level of boldness that's actually disgusting.
Okay, there are so many people looking you in the face and
Does he does he still make does he make eye contact? >> So
important >> because there are so many people looking at
you in the face and lying. It >> is it should we read anything
into the fact that he cannot maintain eye contact with the camera
while saying this?
>> Is this should we read into this that he has to keep
averting his eyes from the camera while he says it?
>> So important because there are so many people looking
at you in the face and lying. It is insane. And by the way, I
just want to address this whether you like or don't like Destiny.
And obviously, you know, I I tried to get along with Destiny
and it it didn't work too well. Okay,
it didn't. But just because I don't with Destiny at all doesn't
mean that I can't acknowledge that bro has been actively threatened
for and and called for the death of multiple times blatantly.
And no one calling for the death of this man has ever been punished.
And I don't
>> um Is that true? I thought Mike got clapped for one
of them. Probably not long enough. Dude, wasn't this freaking
out that Destiny was calling for
like uh or glorifying assassination attempts and
justified if you go to a MAGA rally that you frown and find out?
>> Yeah. Yeah, Mike did get banned. I like and probably
not long enough. Like I I think obviously when you cross the
line into actually doing Calls to Violence, that's a problem.
Uh it it bothered me. I maintain the exact same take I had before
with both of those calls to violence. The Mike one, the uh Sean
one. Like it's always wrong. >> But I don't
I don't know how much that changes any of this stuff here.
>> It's just bizarre.
>> It's Well, I guess what what it should be or how we
should look at it is they're going to dig up every single thing
Twitch has done wrong and regardless of if try Twitch has tried
to fix it or regardless of if they have different policies now,
none of that matters. They're just going to bring up all of the
greatest hits they possibly can while probably avoiding any of
the bad things they've done or any of the things where they,
you know, if Twitch failed to punish one of their friends, they'll
never point that out, right?
Hey guys, are are you guys like really railing against the fact
that Kaiat had a guy nearly strangled to death on his stream
and got no ban for that? You are you guys really upset that Kai
Sonat got back after like a day after fingering a girl live on
stream? Where's the outrage? Where's the outrage about the inconsistent
toos enforcement, guys? Oh, wait. Well, that is not a fan of
Assan, I guess. >> Yeah. Yeah. The inconsistent toos is
like
that part's I don't know.
>> Yeah. The Well, I'm just saying it's like clearly it's
it's like ver just performative. It's just virtue signaling.
But it's fine. These guys have figured out, by the way, they've
put the puzzle together that like, hey, we won't get as much
push back on on Twitter when we complain about this if we also
add that Destiny got threats. We add that. Oh my god. Now suddenly
Twitter's like so much easier for us. Let's go. I >> don't
care who you are. I I'm not going to call for the death of you
ever. Um it's just not good. It's not a good thing to do. Now,
I might tell you to kill yourself, but that's not a threat. That's
just a suggestion. Way different. It is. It It really is. And
I people people need to understand that there's a big difference
>> between a gamer saying, "Ah, bro, kill yourself." Like
in League of Legends, uh
I'm going to come to your house >> in a political debate
with somebody that you disagree with
who's ideologically opposed to you. I don't think there's very
much of a difference. >> You don't I think telling somebody
to kill themselves is way different.
like telling somebody to if you're having a political disagreement
with somebody and telling them to kill >> and then also
saying that you're going to kill somebody.
>> Uh I think you're just wishing death on
>> Just different tactics. >> You're like you're
implying that their life isn't worth living, but there's a directedness
to calling to saying somebody should be that. >> But it's
all political like it's all like a decline in political civility.
>> Sure. It's a decline in civility, but >> you're
unable to have discourse. You're unable to have a debate to >> like
talk through your beliefs >> and you have to resort to
indecency.
>> Yeah, absolutely. >> Whether you want to follow
through with it or whether you're hoping that you break the other
person down or invoke other people to
>> be violent or whatever. Yeah. I don't >> Yeah,
it's all on a sliding scale. I just think um the only thing like
we at least legally consider like a call to violence is something
that requires like um like a call to action. There has to be
some call to action um on on the part of like your audience.
Yeah. >> Yeah.
Anyway, that's my opinion >> and I'm gonna flatter you.
There's a very big difference. There is uh because one is a suggestion
and the other one is telling you these are the actions that I'm
going to do. Man,
it really is odd. And the more and I and I mean this genuinely,
the more you are aware of what's going on in the world, the more
that you are aware of these people that are lying, the more that
these people will try to discredit the people telling the truth.
I mean, I want you to look at Nuaku for an example. Nuaku got
his entire career temporarily destroyed, which he bounced back
from cuz he's >> one of the goats. God bless you, N. Um,
the amount of misinformation put out on this guy.
>> Yeah, I feel like I only ever read lies about Nuaku.
Like Nuku Taku seems totally normal. He seems like a regular
political content creator to me. And I feel like the rest of
it, you know, anybody making noise about this guy, just lying.
Just out here lying about him, trying to ruin his reputation.
>> Like an unhinged cartoon picture. >> I don't I
don't know. I'm just
>> I just feel like uh Techone
Tech's referencing, you know, certain communities been going
after Nux
>> he's not a big fan. >> There's just like an overall
pattern of like really ugly cartoon pictures doing political
commentary that I would like >> I'm going to the bathroom.
I'll be right back. I'm going to get more water. This is unacceptable.
>> Is insane. I mean, dude, I get told that Knox is a daily.
Um and I'm like, brother, what the are you talking about? just
complete.
>> Why do they keep trying to defend themselves on the
lolly? No, you are both you've both made really weird comments
very consistently throughout your careers about drawn images
of kids. Okay, you've both done it. Stop trying to virtue signal
like you like that's totally insane that that happened. You may
have Asmin Gold on your side now, but just wait until Asmin Gold
has to go answer for any of the [__] you've said
in the past. Okay. >> Yeah. Yeah, >> just wait until
he has to look his chat in the eye and go, "Yeah, when he talked
about having that 8-year-old's feet in his mouth and then tried
to save it with when she's 18, that was totally cool and I comment."
>> And here's what I need. I need this, Teone. If you are
not that person, right? If you if you're just being edgy on the
internet, you need to admit that you say weird gross like that
because your fans like it and that's what gets them to watch
you and donate to you. You have to >> I'm not a I just
I just monetize. You're not a admit to laring as a I don't care.
Both of them are you're weird to me. If you lar as a or you lar
defending, something's wrong with you. >> You got no moral
compass. You're broken.
>> You got like the one from Jack Sparrow. It points wherever
the [__] you want it to go and it's always pointing
towards where the money is. >> Misrepresentations
of the truth. And I I mean this genuinely. Nucks has always been
good to me and I'm a guy who's always going to have the back
of my friends. However, I will also be the first guy to hold
my friends accountable. Uh like for example, sorry, I got something
in my eye. I was the first guy to call it Asthma Gold a massive
when he uses big fat build and elder ring cuz he's not good enough
to beat the game any other way. Anyways, um just think about
how much misinformation is put out on Aszmagold as well. uh or
even legal mindset, you know, or even me. Um I'm sure everybody
at a point of watching my videos has probably seen me be accused
of doing the worst crimes on planet Earth. Um guys, I I'm Whoa,
camera almost fell down. Getting a little bit gusty here in San
Antonio. Um I want to remind you that there was even rumors that
I killed people.
Yes, there was even a point in time where people thought I was
murdering people. Uh, yes, I've been accused of everything on
the earth that there is to be accused of. And what's really scary
is
there are more people willing to believe baseless
>> And look at Omnilelettic's chat. >> What's that?
>> he says, "Jo agreeing with Cherry right now after spending
a year defending Mr. Girl because he only pretended to be a
>> by law." I just said that that the story was a thought
experiment. That's why I said it repeatedly. >> I have
been good with Max way before I from before I met Jtock. I'm
pretty sure >> and it's obvious it's a thought experiment
because the story changes wildly depending on where he's telling
it. So
>> listen, if you got filtered by that one, you aren't
going to be able to have any further conversations after that.
That's like the that's like the lowest bar for watching Mr. Girl
content. >> Yeah. And
mind you, while I was like still in the DG sphere, I was like
one of the people who thought Max telling that story, that's
a story. I don't like that. I like I was fine with Max. Max and
I were friends and Yeah. I didn't I thought that >> violation
for sure.
>> Yeah. But it's a question about like what it it was
it was framing a conversation.
Um but he did actually violate that woman's consent.
because I I know that because I asked him and he said yes I did.
She said no and then I did it anyway. So
yeah that's what it is >> and grounded truths. And let
me tell you why this is there is two sides of your brain. There
is the very quick reactionary emotional side of your brain and
then there is the slow logical version of your brain. Now the
majority of people
are really going to fall victim to the short emotional side of
their brain because that is how >> dude I
>> these guys are actually explaining exact they're explaining
exactly how they work. They're explaining their audience to their
audience and then telling them actually I'm explaining everybody
else to you. >> I don't want to learn anything from >> It's
crazy. It's crazy. >> We have been wired as human beings
to consume content whether that's big dramatic headlines or clickbait
titles. Can you believe they did this? I mean, there's a reason
why more Pegasus videos work so well, because my god, the clickbait
is insane. Hey, don't hate the player, hate the game. Um, this
is >> true. But we feed into our emotional reactionary
side of our brain a lot quicker than our slower, logical side
of our brain, which really >> dude, imagine imagine figuring
this concept out in your 30s and not in your 20s. leads to.
>> Now, imagine in your 30s you didn't figure it out. Someone
just emailed you. >> Yeah, I there's and I guess that that's
like obviously true because of how he gives into the like illogical
emotional side of his brain all the time. >> I think >> like
it's clear he didn't have any understanding or any any remote
understanding of this like a month ago. I literally need to drop
this idea like I need to be an expert or I have to go get a PhD
or something to make YouTube videos on some like pretty basic
stuff because people learn something and in two days feel like
I need to make a YouTube video and teach others. >> Yeah,
I don't even have a problem with that. It's it's when I see the
people who are like openly lying and weaponizing like these concepts
and the things they're doing. Like literally, if you just aren't
looking to be outright like uh an outright liar for money, as
long as that's like the bar, you're totally fine. If you have
like some good intention at all, you're perfect. Like there's
so many people who are just outright like, "Oh, I know I'm wrong.
I'm just going to lie because >> am I wrong or do you just
have like the wrong definition of the word I'm using?" Actually,
if you if you scroll down, I'm using the fourth iteration of
the word
>> Oh boy.
>> You know, people want to believe uh what they already
think. Um no one, a lot of people aren't really going to be like,
hm, this thing that I greatly believe in. I'm going to look at
things that disprove it. Most people aren't like that. Now, I've
been like that a lot more often, uh generally over the past two
years, and I think that's made me a lot more complete of an individual.
Uh
>> uh I think either one of these guys watching the Shimu
video in full, watch both Shimu videos on Asmin Gold or sorry
on Teone. If you're Asmin Gold or if you're Techone, if either
one of them are willing to watch both in full and give a tangible
response, then
I will stop calling him rapetone. Okay, no more rape. Rape tone
will be totally >> Um but one of the things on, you know,
the left side, the Hassan side, is this thing called cognitive
dissonance. And Sasha Gray is a great example of this where Sasha
Gray is so down bad for Hassan that even when she makes claims
that Hassan never even had a dog collar on the dog and there
was no prongs and then she watched a clip showing exactly that,
she had such an emotional
>> So I would say it's probably an emotional reaction to
see the cutie Cinderella clip where Cutie Cinderella is saying
what she thinks and then to go that's proof that what she said
is correct. Does he not understand like what proof is of something?
Right? It's like, oh, some person who says they're friends with
Assan just said this. That's proof that whatever they said is
the truth. Like, oh, >> this is also his insult is just
utter projection. The idea that Sasha Gray, oh, you must be down
bad for Hassan,
right? She must just be attracted to Hassan. That's why she's
defending him. >> I'm sorry, Tech. Is that why you are
defending Emmy? No, he's he's protecting his dad's queen there.
>> His dad, >> right? His dad is one interesting
Emmy. >> His dad's down bad for Emmy. Yeah. >> Introduces
dad to her and put in a good word. Yeah. Yeah. >> Claims
that Hassan never even had a dog collar on the dog and there
was no prongs. And then she watched a clip showing exactly that.
She had such an emotional reaction where she got angry and she
rage quit the clip because she couldn't accept that her version
of reality was augmented, that it wasn't real, that it wasn't
rooted in reality and it made her copyright claim in DMCA strike
anybody who showcased that clip because she can't accept that
she's wrong. This is like me with uh the people in chat when
I go watch that anything else clip of Dan showing what the prongs
look like when they're cut down and you can still clearly see
the prongs. Everyone can see them. They're visible to everybody
and he's going, "Look, you can't even see them. You can't even
see them." Keeps turning it over. You can see it from every single
angle. You can't even see it. You can't even tell it's there
anymore. >> Do you think there's anything wrong with her
just getting those clips taken down of her?
>> Yeah, definitely. She's using DMCA to do it. Yeah. >> But
do you think it's wrong? Yeah.
Yeah. You shouldn't be a public creator who does stuff and then
people comment on it publicly, right? Or it's like used in some
way that's like clearly fair use or follow follows most of the
the requirements of fair use and then you use DMCA to take it
down. >> Who? Sasha Gray. So Sasha Gray did make a post
saying she made like a claim, right, that the prongs,
what was it, that they can't get taken >> that they can't
be removed. >> They can't be removed. So obviously it's
not a shock collar. That was her take.
>> Yeah. Well, that that like the prongs weren't there
at all and like they couldn't be removed and it's like no, you
could definitely like remove them
>> Yes. And so I guess did she readress it or anything?
>> She also said there was no tape on the back of it and
that that was like
>> There's like two incorrect statements and I don't know
if she addressed it afterwards, but the instant move was to
claim and get them taken down. the clips that people were posting
about her. >> I don't even know if it's the instant move
or if she tried responding. It was like the next day. I don't
know how quickly. Not >> It has to be that she has a manager
or something, right? Because I She's not going to do that. >> Yeah.
I have no idea. >> She has somebody protecting her image
or >> Well, I and I mean I have no idea how any of these
sites verify the DMCA stuff either that it's coming from the
the correct person. If it's getting DMCA on Reddit, then I have
no idea how they verify that.
>> Has she made any statement about it? >> I Yeah,
I don't know. I know you're asking Chad, but I don't know. >> there
are so many people trying to discredit the people who are telling
the truth, it's a little bit scary. And there's this content
creator uh by the name of Milo, who I believe left the internet
uh back in 2015.
Uh guy is very racist. It's hilarious.
John Dei,
never mind. >> It's hilarious that he's very racist. >> Is
he talking about Yiannopoulos, by the way? Yes, he is. >> Okay.
Um, Milo has brain cancer. Bro, be sensitive. Okay. >> I'm
not going to lie. I thought it was [__] hilarious.
Uh, there's a
>> other internet every once in a while to go on a drug
vendor, right? >> And then he comes back and spills a bunch
of tea. >> He does. Yeah. For real. Yeah. I think Milo
Milo made a post talking about how he probably has a brain tumor.
>> He thinks. Yeah. And he's like, which is [__]
up. >> He said it's not guaranteed. He said he has to get
more tests, but he said it's very likely that that's what's going
on. >> Didn't he He has some tweet where he's like, "If
I made it this far without AIDS, like come on." >> It's
that tweet. Yeah. He was like, "I can't believe God did this
when he like protected me from AIDS." Basically, it's in that
same tweet. Yeah.
I'm not going to lie. I thought it was hilarious. Uh there's
this other streamer by the name of Cuffam who uh went viral for
having this clip versus this Mexican guy where they were both
calling each other racial slurs. And uh that clip was hilarious.
You know, it was it was hilarious. Um
and guys, I I'm tired of pretending that this [__]
isn't funny. There's so many people who will tell you >> massive
massive what a what a huge go. Teone is an intellectual giant.
in 2025. He goes, "Actually,
I find Milo Yiannopoulos funny." What a brave statement, guys.
I I actually thought Milo Yiannopoulos was hilarious. Okay, I
don't Lots of people did. Lots of people find him funny. He's
a provocator. I don't You're literally
>> It's You're saying nothing. And then he's like, "Oh,
also two different ethnic minorities in the US calling each other
slurs." That's That's hilarious, guys. I'm tired of pretending
it's not. video probably had 10 million views. I don't think
anyone was pretending that it wasn't funny. >> When When
did Elon buy Twitter?
>> Elon Musk.
>> 2023. Okay. Techone is like >> 2 years too late.
>> He's like jumping on board with the Come on. Can't Can't
we just like normalize being racist on the internet? Can we all
just like take a joke? It's like funny. >> 2022, by the
way. >> Okay. 2022. He's three years behind. >> Yep.
Oh, I love everything. I love everyone. I'm accepting of everything.
I'm so tolerant. This, that, and the other. No, you're just a
piece of [__] And that's a
video for another time. Um, which I might record immediately
right now because I think it's worth discussing. But, um, yeah,
cognitive dissonance is running wild, as well as another great
one, the fallacy of relative provation, which is you can't
>> That's definitely something he learned this week.
Oh my god.
P pro privation.
Relative privation. >> Be upset at this thing because there's
a war in Gaza happening right now. There's a genocide in Palestine.
Yeah. Uh unfortunately, just because there's something worse
happening elsewhere doesn't mean that your current issue doesn't
exist. Regardless,
lots of things.
>> This is so perfect. He said fallacy. So, how long until
he's on a debate panel?
Who the is going down the lines of like fallacies and cognitive
dissonance if they're not trying to roll in the mud? >> Um,
that tone because Asmin Gold's done it like basically completely
successfully for whatever period of time.
Um, relative privation is
>> um, you don't have it bad. They're like starving kids
in relative privation. Yeah, they're starving kids in Africa
right now. So, don't complain about your >> It's the appeal
to worse problems. Basically, I don't have to listen to you because
there are worse things going on.
>> Things to enjoy today. Lots of things to consume.
And rage culture is fed higher than ever. And everybody calling
out the truth is villainized. And everybody lying is considered
a just a good old squeaky clean boy. And my god am I tired of
it. Um yeah, do me a favor. Fact check everything. I think it'll
make your life much better. And uh really just observe. I mean,
we paused what, three or four times at the beginning of this
video to pause and go, "Oh, he's totally lying about this. He's
totally lying about that. He's totally lying about this other
thing." V. The astrourfing on Twitter, how everyone will say
the exact same comment, most likely from fraudulent users or
fake users in general where they say, "Hey, this guy who's literally
saying things that have been proven on camera, well, he's delusional.
He's skitso. He's obsessed." Um, yes, I am obsessed. I am obsessed
with pushing the truth. And side note for anybody who sat through
um this entire video,
I can't wait to prove all of you guys who are part of my community
correct. There's a lot of things in this world that I could have
already dealt with, but I'm not. And the reason why I'm not is
because it's leading to a lot of mask off moments. I'm getting
a lot of information that I want. And uh man, there's going to
be cinema. >> This is uh this is our our Miz hints. Okay,
this is our miz drama vague
I I'm going to call it now. Okay, I feel like these guys have
oversold the they have on >> Miz is so disappointing.
>> I'm I'm agreeing with you. I'm agreeing with you. >> just
keep going. Keep spinning. >> Oh, yeah. I I think they're
like so I I think they're way overselling what they've got on
Miz. I think whatever their nuke is is going to be almost nothing.
And there will be I I don't think there'll be any blowback cuz
I think Miz is so rich right now. His reputation is so rich that
he will just get like overrun completely. >> Do it almost
feels like they were playing chicken that they were hoping that
Miz is so PTSD about everything that happened that Asmin go just
being like I will set it straight if he if he starts I will.
And then like Msk will just go into panic attack mode, sit in
the corner and be like I'm I'm just going to take another two
weeks off. Uh, like the way that it seemed like Mitch Jones was
about to start streaming and then he just [__] disappeared
in >> I think it's going to be one of two things. I think
it's going to be one, um, like I said, I it's going to be him
bullying Techone, him calling Teone like a or something. One,
and then two, it will be that he probably asked Emmy not to collab
with people. He probably, you know, let his like depression,
his depression affect his relationship and push Emmy away, right?
And it's going to be from any other lens. Any lens except this
guy's like evil. You go like, "Yeah, it's kind of relationship
sometimes. That's up, man." But for for this, it's going to be
like people are just going to go, "Oh, Misc is so
>> Oh my god. You mean to tell me your
uh streamer boyfriend has a fragile ego
>> can't handle it to 10,000 people instead of 50,000 people.
>> He wants you to soo it and to take care of him.
>> That's it. That's all it is. What a monster. If that's
it. If that's it. Asmin Gold is ridiculous.
>> Asmin Gold's ridiculous. Techone's ridiculous. I guess
we knew they were ridiculous already.
Techone is calling out Jtock and Queman, but they were both scared
to call him out and just react behind video hours after videos
hours after he posted it. Imagine if Teone presses them. Do you
Okay, Lceto again. >> Well, that's the thing. That's why
I feel like when he uses the words uses a a fallacy or whatever
and brings up cognitive dissonance,
I don't even know. Did he use it correctly in this video? Did
he elaborate on it whatsoever? >> He just like name dropping.
>> I think he got relative probation correct more or less
that like it's the oh there's a genocide going on. Stop focusing
on this. >> I think he got >> Nobody can live by
that. You literally never get to complain. Someone is always
going to have a bigger problem than you in that regard. >> Oh.
Oh man, >> because then he has to shut the up. >> I
know. Yes, I know you guys are hinting at this that he's getting
emails. I just realized that probably because of his alignment
with Dan and because of people's disillusionment with Destiny,
he is probably getting some of the old emailers who would have
emailed Destiny and been like, "Here's actually how you make
this argument." >> They just have totally moved over to
Tech like here's how you make this argument, Techone. >> You're
a trutht teller. >> This is actually what's happening.
>> It's actually a fallacy. >> Yeah. Uh
god, that's that's really funny. >> Reason why I'm not
is because it's leading to a lot of mask off moments. I'm getting
a lot of information that I want and uh man, there's going to
be cinema soon to come and I'm really enjoying it. Uh always
make sure to leave one in the chamber. Uh but for me, I like
to leave a fully loaded mag.
I will see you guys. I want I want Teone to stand up and go,
"Misk was totally up for calling me a" and then he has to defend
against all of the clips of him saying outrageous [__]
about drawn images of kids. Okay, that's what we need. He He
needs to stand on business and go this was totally up for saying
I'm a and then actually have to deal with all of those clips.
I because we've already heard Asmin Gold say this is like what
Teton's mad about. Teone was like being mocked. Teone was being
bullied, right? And then he said he's being bullied called a
for a weird weird degenerate or whatever the and it's like no
te was those things quite literally that was his brand just like
Lucari had a very similar brand and now he's like doing this
shift and you guys are pretending Miskf was wrong for saying
any of those things. >> And how long until Emmy R said
that when she gets home from TwitchCon that's when she's going
to do the video explaining what Asmin Gold says is going to be
like so much worse.
>> Right. Well,
bigger way bigger drama than whatever is going on TwitchCon.
Which also is just funny. If you guys thought Listen, you think
Emir gettings salted as drama? Just wait until you see how she's
Miz's reputation. Okay. It's like, it's like, okay, like, isn't
this your friend? Why are you saying that you got way bigger
drama coming than just Emiru getting insulted in your video talking
about Emiru getting insulted?
You guys think this one was wild? Just wait until the next one.
Just wait until the next one, guys.
I don't It's just a little bizarre. That's all.
Uh I did I cut Tech sign >> Uh but for me, I like to leave
a fully loaded mag.
>> I will see you guys very soon. There's going to be lots
of great things happening. Some sooner, some later, but uh I
appreciate you guys and thanks for watching. See you on the next
one. >> By the way, I I don't know for sure cuz I've never
gotten specifics, but I have had people who live in Austin tell
me that like Techone,
this is going to be like I think they're going to have almost
nothing against each other. Okay. I think Teto is gonna have
some vague bullying stuff. Maybe Emia will uh sorry uh Emirou
will say something along the lines of like he was, you know,
he was telling me I couldn't collab with these people or whatever.
That'll be the one thing. But what'll actually be massive is
the other smaller creators coming forward to make allegations
against each one like the against Misk and against Techone. I
think that's what'll happen is you'll see it like actually spiral
out to a bunch of like a bunch of allegations coming from people
who weren't actually involved in this initial drama. >> We
heard stuff about that
around last year from the uh Darius IRL house, right? Just talking
about cuz they would always go to the Austin parties and they
knew that there were people iced out from the OTK house. >> Mhm.
Yep. >> And stuff like that. >> Yeah. Yeah. That's
where I mean that's how I would have heard about a lot of this
stuff. It's explicitly how I heard about it. So,
>> yeah, let me see here. And with that, I think we're
done with the Twitch roundup for the night, guys. I think we're
going to finally get into >> Also, people conservative
drama. >> Do a show. I would like to stream very late tonight
so we can fix our sleep schedule. We should do like a 12 hour
24-hour stream. >> Okay. Well, you can sign up for that.
>> I'm signing up right now. >> Okay. Uh, let's see.
We're going to do the this one. We're going to do the Andrew
Wilson, Rob Noir
drama. The the panel verse drama. Okay. And yeah, guys, listen.
If you like the content, go ahead. Throw a couple subs in the
bucket. All right. Throw a couple subs. Throw some donos in.
>> If you start subbing, we can get him to start taking
caffeine.
>> All right. I'm going to reset the bar. I probably We
probably are adding more time already to be honest with you.
We have uh we probably have enough for I think 5 hours 40. >> We
can do it. >> Well, we I mean we've gotten the donations
for it. I just didn't add it right away. So, we got this. I'm
going >> I'm telling off Ryan as we Okay, we have to get
the back lure. Wait, what did he